control insiders this will be over and
over to lead it by an any big fat love
fly common ground to hold the spread of
light and we must do it big fat love
flying common ground to hold the spread
of Lies
America First America First
fatal we want to build a much better
believable people and we must do it
non-fatal communication very much higher
America first to lead it by than any
insiders fighting for insiders time to
stop insiders fighting for insiders more
of insiders fighting for insiders time
to stop insiders fighting for insiders
America First Love the flow
now it's time for new believable people
and we must do it if we don't control
insiders this will be over and over to
lead it by an any big fat love flying
common ground to hold the spread of lies
and we must do it big fat love flying
common ground to hold a spread of lives
and any America First America first
we want to build a much better
believable people and we must do it not
fatal communication very much higher
America first to lead it by an any
insiders fighting for insiders time to
stop insiders fighting for insiders more
of insiders fighting for insiders time
to stop insiders fighting for insiders
America First Love the flow
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
reach the wizard
[Music]
s
it's fun
[Music]
love the flow
69. now it's time for new believable
people and we must do it if we don't
control insiders this will be over and
over to lead it by an any big fat love
flying common ground to hold the spread
of lies and we must do it big fat love
it's like common ground hold the spread
of Lies
America First America First
fatal we want to build a much better
believable people and we must do it
non-fatal communication very much higher
America first to lead it by an any
insiders fighting for insiders time to
stop insiders fighting for insiders more
of insiders fighting for insiders time
to stop it's Fighters fighting for
insiders America First Love the flow
69. now it's time for new believable
people and we must do it
if we don't control insiders this will
be over and over to lead by an any big
fat love find common ground to Halt the
spread of lies and we must do a big fat
love it's like common ground to hold the
spread of lives
[Music]
America first
we want to build a much better
believable people and we must do it
non-fatal communication very much higher
America first to lead by any insiders
fighting for insiders time to stop
insiders fighting for insiders more of
insiders fighting for insiders time to
stop insiders fighting for insiders
America First Love the flow
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
woke up again
call me back
[Music]
no no no no
does that sound like a baby
[Music]
don't you make things
back when I was in the academy
we would follow every
[Music]
American president is
like the Domino he's got that Sinister
smiling thinks he just might win the bet
but he's just hanging on
dangling like hunt a cigarette hundred
times
[Music]
foreign
are you
[Music]
start your feet up the street hump your
back stiff in your arms I'm pulling back
life's hard you know when entering in
the Cadillac if you wanna know where it
stops it ends in dementia and the cops
[Music]
then they arrest all these men while
Putin laughs
[Music]
he's owned by them and ukrainians all
the cops in the doj said
foreign
[Music]
walk like a Joe Biden
remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at louder with
crowder.com mug club for 89 annually
join the fight at lottery.com mug club
today
[Music]
[Applause]
what I know
[Music]
thank you
yeah look at that
[Laughter]
it is time for uh for geo I did this so
you can tell the difference from the
thumbnail from GOP debate number one
it'll it'll probably go away uh by
tomorrow thank God Welcome to the
oh please I'll pay you ten dollars a
week to leave that on it sounded like a
kid had to make a wish like no no please
remind me of a gay Aunt well
before the show he said Dave Schultz and
then he has to no Larry Robinson all
right all right that's fine uh glad to
be with you so it is the Geo bring it up
there in the lower third so people can
see nothing up our sleeves uh it is the
GOP debate stream so now you can use the
hashtag Crowder debate night you can use
it on on the X used to be Twitter you
can use it anywhere that you're on
social media and you can also use it as
a promo code you get ten dollars off
later with credit.com mug Club 79
annually you get this wonderful hand
etched girthy mug and uh you get Nick
depaolo who's with me here every day at
five I mean you can still get a portion
of his free show everywhere you get free
podcast but you get extra show at mug
Club Nick how are you sir good I'm a
girl at the Italian oh come on now he's
saying that because he's been he's lost
weight and he's looking very slim and so
he's he's fishing for coming I put on
five since I last saw you so really yes
muscle oh no actual pure sausage and
peppers and pizza crust and raw dough
with the sausage coming
well aside from Nikki Haley that brings
us to the debate stream tonight it
absolutely is a sausage fest I mean but
look we're gonna have Chris Christie on
screen we'll do a side by side it'll
make you feel good about yourself we
feel good about life decisions boy the
fangs they're out early
it's ought to be a fun night
I'm your gay on I'm supposed to be sassy
oh we're a couple
um so uh look there's a lot to get to
here tonight uh first off you guys can
comment what do you think we can expect
here tonight
um and I know a lot of you saying why do
we really care people are not super
enthusiastic about this debate because
not a whole lot changed since the last
debate as far as money raised as far as
the polls switching Donald Trump is
still leading by well into the double
digits but look I want you guys to focus
on one thing here tonight the media okay
the media we have every everyone combing
MSNBC CNN all of social media the
meltdowns that are going to be happening
these people are proxies for Donald
Trump tonight how they choose to attack
or if they choose to try and ingratiate
themselves to the Trump voters that'll
be interesting but the media is not
going to give anyone a fair Shake
remember I've always told you this it
doesn't matter if you're Trump if you're
George W bush if you're Ron DeSantis
Whoever has an R next to their name is
going to get the Trump treatment period
and you will see it on display tonight
for everyone to see especially because
they are scared they are scared when you
look at the recent polls before I go to
the drinking game rules
the recent Washington Post ABC poll to
give you an idea so there's the RCP
average Donald Trump is ahead by about
1.4 I believe 1.4 points uh the recent
Washington Post ABC poll let me bring
this up here because all the references
are lotto's crowder.com uh what is the
new do you have the do you have it yeah
I've got it right now so it's got Trump
52 Biden 42. yeah give us the spread 10
points yeah 10 points not a math genius
but the wapo ABC has Trump up by 10
points that's the most recent poll not a
Bastion of conservatism now here's some
context if you look at the last
elections right uh with Washington Post
ABC uh September 2015. Clinton she was
up by three Biden September 2019 was up
by 17. so that scale matters Trump being
ahead by any points is more than down by
17. yeah that's a 27 point difference
and how did they explain it even
Washington Post ABC I think I was
reading through and they're like uh we
basically didn't get to the right people
they were saying that this variability
in the poll it does this isn't the
normal poll this is probably an outlier
poll I know that we just paid a whole
bunch of money to get this thing out
there but uh it doesn't really reflect
accurately what what the issues are it
literally said something like yeah
Washington Post ABC they had to
apologize for doing a bad job their own
poll and by doing a bad job I mean they
basically just ask people what they
thought and didn't spin it there's a
poll didn't work we didn't have the
right ball bearings it's all ball
bearings nowadays kids uh hit the like
button if you're watching on YouTube
okay we're going going to post a
drinking game rules here in a second
which I don't even know if we have to uh
I mean we have to let people know the
YouTube dump up with the drinking game
rules yeah so if you're watching on
YouTube and at any point you see this
that means head on over to rumble that's
our home and they're being attacked by
International governments right they are
yes drinking game rules for tonight
bring them up to a man all right they
are if uh Trump is mentioned the word
indictment is used Frank Chris Christie
has a fake tough guy moment that's gonna
be a lot Vivek attacks anybody well uh
DeSantis talks using his thumb yep I
finished drink someone brings up Ronald
Reagan and they are at the Reagan
Library oh wow so uh I'm tossed really
yeah also uh anytime there's a thug life
moment you have to finish it yeah right
oh yeah that's true last time I was
there I was there with a Alan Covert of
the Adam and uh uh what's his name Ron
Howard's brother Clint Howard that's the
Ronald Reagan Library there's a bizarre
too you say Alan Combs Alan Covert not
Alan Combs he's dead I know but you said
last time so the singer of Smash Mouth
and I only found out after we did a
Smash Smash Mouth sketch this week like
you know he's dead too and we're like
now we gotta run it like you and I we
did a five minute Riff on Sinead
O'Connor like you know she died right I
was like no I didn't Nick's like I knew
yeah like what do you think I laid it
that's why I did it I got drunk for two
days and I saw that
celebratory bed well you don't drink to
make a bad day good only to make a good
day better and I think that was one of
those days
if I don't ever have to hear Hey the
next time Conor McGregor walks out I
consider it a win uh does he play her
stuff he does but he replaced her with
Melissa Etheridge so now it's come to my
window
there's another last being I don't know
all right we do have some montages here
uh some clips to show you guys because
Donald Trump skipped this debate that's
that's a tactical decision and by the
way I would say is right of him to do he
did it to speak to the UAW workers and
so we've been working on this we're
going to actually come back to this
later let me tell you this I think this
is a smart move because Donald Trump I
was shocked when we covered that
election he won Michigan he won the
Midwest I'm just hoping that he's not
pandering to the UAW because if you
Pander to the UAW you're actually
screwing all of the other workers in the
midwest so I believe that we have this
Montage right Gerald what are you they
have a trump Montage for you over there
no they have the current event Montage
two minutes long let me give you quickly
they're putting together a clip Montage
of Donald Trump's speech but I was
listening to it and talking with the
guys beforehand he isn't bowing down to
the UAW you and I were talking about
this before he can go there and support
the working class citizens that the base
the people who are the members of the
UAW without actually supporting the
leadership of the UAW he did a really
good job of threading that needle
basically he had one of his quotes he's
like look it doesn't matter the deal you
get in two years you're all out of a job
anyway right he but he had those kind of
moments again that we love from Donald
Trump where he's very honest with him
like go negotiate it's not going to
matter they're trying policies on you
that all these vehicles have to be
electric or up to a certain percentage
in 10 years he's like do you think
that's going to happen your jobs went to
Mexico your jobs went to China this
Administration doesn't care about you
and also your leaders don't care about
you because they always support the
Democrat so he split them like we do
with China and the CCP where like
Chinese people good CCP bad he's doing
the same thing well not all Chinese
people all right small hands they can
get in crevices folks yeah but so you
know we'll have a montage of some of the
highlights for that and then throughout
the night as we go other moments from
that that we want to bring up we will
bring it out scooters from China they're
making a lot of electric scooters can
move around too fast for the scooter
it's not structurally sound you go 45
downhill it's gonna be a bad crash folks
but no here's the thing a lot of
Democrats switched over because of TPP
the trans-pacific partnership because of
free trade and that is I will say that
has single-handedly from Donald Trump
that's what shifted the Republican Party
quite a bit to becoming the party of the
working class and I will tell you this I
was never a protectionist but I
certainly um saw the value in
highlighting the the disproportionate uh
the agreements that were so weighted
toward China and these International
agreements that we had that really did
screw the American now not a pro
pro-union guy Pro UAW guy if it comes
down to communist American unions or
communist crap from China we'll look
communist crap from China is cheaper but
the agreements that we had if you look
at free it was never free trade the
terrorists that were putting on our
Goods going over there Donald Trump is
focusing on what he won he in uh in the
2016 election he did and let me give you
some stats that he put out from this
right so he had a press release to put
all these stats out there the United
States added I think you've got an
overlay potentially there that you can
bring up from that on air added 510 new
510 000 new manufacturing jobs between
Trump's election and February of 2020
right so that's the number we typically
use is pre-covered right so that's
essentially what he's doing there 510
000. 2018 the United States added 264
000 new manufacturing jobs the most in
30 years he's got a record with these
people he doesn't have to go make
promises right he can go and tell them I
will do for you now what I did for you
before yeah and nobody else can do that
with them well that's the that's the
context here right is eight years of
Obama yeah three years of Donald Trump
and then they're going to have four
years of Biden and they mirror I mean
for just Ukraine for crying out loud
here's what what Obama did when you look
at what happened in Crimea when you look
at what happened uh with TPP and you
look at what Biden is doing and how weak
he is on China when you look at
bidenomics which is really just another
version of shovel ready jobs and
printing money they have no economic
plan it's robbing from Peter to pay Paul
shovel ready jobs we talked about this
in northern Michigan there's what they
call up north trees it's after the Great
Depression where they said we have
shovel ready jobs they just paid a bunch
of people here go dig a tree and they
didn't know how to plant a tree and so
they had a bunch of trees that couldn't
grow leaves because they were planted
too close to each other that's not a
real job where you see the difference if
you take away nothing else it's private
sector job growth versus government
employees well sure you just decrease
the unemployment rate if you just added
80 000 IRS sorry not agents employees
it's 87 000 not agents sorry employees a
bunch of pencil pushing pencil pushing
just gelatinous next with blocks what
could possibly go wrong so if you just
keep adding jobs through your tax
dollars well you can always artificially
manipulate the unemployment numbers so
uh that is I think a really strong
um it's a strong argument and it's also
he did a good job with that speech I was
very worried that he was going to go up
and do something that made him look like
he was supporting the actual union
bosses but he called them out and he
said it's a miracle they always support
I wish they would support Donald Trump
yeah well they can always support the
Democrat he just says it so dramatically
did he bring up the the argument about
the wage increase did he get that
specific they want a 40 wage increase no
they want more than that but they want
their wage increase I think their costs
would go from what from 60 something an
hour to 150 plus dollars an hour they
want 40 Hour Work Week pay for 30 hour
work week yeah didn't we already learned
yeah no no remember Toyota couldn't make
money because uh they were losing money
on cars yes well that's Obama right
Donald Trump did a great job of walking
right past and going doesn't matter what
the deal is doesn't matter what the deal
is their policies kill your industry
they've been doing it for decades and
it's going to happen again if you do not
vote for me okay so before that let's
show the clips of Biden really quickly
with the UAW this is pandra so since I'm
hearing the speech went well with Donald
Trump again send in your predictions use
the promo code hashtag Crowder debate
and I have to look down because I never
remember my own promo because we have it
can we put it there it's a proud of
debate isn't there is there a hashtag do
we have a hashtag all right uh you can
see Biden just pandering the UAW again
99 of their their donations go to
Democrats uh so he just says yeah yeah
you should get more and then we'll
compare that with Donald Trump and then
we'll go into
um what's happened since the last debate
and what we can expect tonight but let's
show the first Biden clip with the UAW
you want me to play them back to back
the first time in our country's history
that is sitting USA president all right
has came out and stood on the picket
line back to the matter is that
you guys of UAW you saved the automobile
industry back in 2008 and before made a
lot of sacrifices gave up a lot and the
companies were all seven people there
now they're doing incredibly well I
don't know if you know this the UAW
Knicks they made a lot of sacrifices
they made a lot of sacrifices with it
with a 60 or 80 billion dollar bailout
yeah three retirees per active worker
they made a lot of sacrifices they did
raise your need and other benefits
he was talking into the wrong end of
that thing for like a half off he was
blowing his hair back
one of those new megaphones my gosh so
uh we're going to have Donald Trump for
12 minutes I think he was in the state
of Michigan physically for about an hour
before he flew to Hollywood for a
fundraiser it just shows how greedy and
selfish Democrats are that's the one
thing that we'll constantly try and make
Republicans everyone here by the way
who's worked for a living obviously and
then once you reach a certain level of
running a company or success all of a
sudden you're not working class why is
it greedy why is it selfish for people
here to not want to pay someone else's
salary through their taxes and it's not
considered selfish for a UAW worker
who's been bailed out at the taxpayers
teat now at least two times if you look
at the subsidies really you're going
into four or five times why is it not
greedy for them to want to cost a
company 150 something dollars an hour
while you and I and other people who by
the way can still make good livings
don't get Cadillac benefits why is why
is it really they sacrificed a lot
LASIK in every Chevy Cavalier you're
paying for you have any idea the
benefits that these guys get the
Cadillac you know you should say that's
the Cadillac of that's the Cadillac of
forks the Cadillac isn't even the
Cadillac of cars anymore because of the
UAW when was the last time a Cadillac
was used as anything other than a
pejorative that is absolutely Fair we
have the uh the Trump speech is still
going on if we wanted to tune in for
well we've got it we've only got about
two and a half minutes till the debate
kicks off so let's you want to talk
about the debate what do you think Nick
what do you anticipate tonight I
anticipate uh hopefully you see more
kellyanne Conway she said face work done
she almost looks like a Fox anchor I'm
sorry
not very tasteful when they bring her on
they play
[Laughter]
what do I anticipate as far as a debate
yes uh once again my boy the Vic yeah
when I say my boy Trump's my boy but I'm
just saying this guy from the guys on
the stage this guy will be uh he's gonna
be in the cabinet of any Republican that
wins this
um he is going to once again be at the
end of this end of the night they'll be
talking about him well he had a bump
after the last debate and then he kind
of sunk back a little bit and and he
lost about two points in the polls but
it's like what he went from five to went
from six to three I mean at this point
it's just yeah I think he's at five
right now but he's somewhere around the
polls because
they don't reflect what people are
thinking they shape what people are
thinking keep that no I don't disagree I
don't disagree but when a leftist poll
has Trump ahead by 10 that is worth it
that's unbelievable that's he's ahead by
110 yes exactly I mean yeah just just
for Washington Post ABC
6.6 is that's it that's his that's his
thing right now 14 points in the
primaries right now that's a 42.2 point
spread but nobody has ever lost a
primary with that kind of margin sorry
go ahead Nick I was gonna say but think
about we have witnessed the worst
presidency and we really have it's it's
been an embarrassment in a world that
wasn't corrupt yeah it'd be up by
seriously it would be 90. yeah it just I
have trouble believing these polls I
think I know they give us something I
don't know why talking some Karl Rove is
on screen but I hope someone gives him a
muppet let's run a quick uh we have some
clips here of what transpired since the
last debate and then we'll go uh live
Haley with a black eye and her stockings
rolling up under a house okay let's show
it and the major question going into
this first debate was whether they ate
candidates on stage could or would do
something to change the basic
pattern or trajectory of this race
that's so far been dominated by the
front runner Donald Trump who skipped
tonight citing his commanding lead
well with the debate wrapping up it
appears for now that the status quo
probably will remain and there's mixed
opinions on who had the best night
according to this poll from The Drudge
Report Vivek ramaswamy won last night's
debate followed by Nikki Haley and Ron
DeSantis with Asa Hutchinson at the
bottom didn't qualify for today
as many people are annoyed by my rise
and believe that a 38 year old is too
young to be U.S president governor
DeSantis will take center stage in
California tonight for the second GOP
debate according to recent polls
Governor DeSantis has fallen behind out
of New Hampshire he has just 10 percent
of the poll behind Trump roughly tied
with Rama Swami Haley and Christy Nikki
Haley holds second place on her own
outside the margin of error in the new
Saint Anselm College Survey Center pool
all right South Carolina governor is at
15 percent
Donald Trump's commanding 45 percent but
clearly ahead of Ron DeSantis let's show
folks from our new poll exactly how
steep it is look at this Donald Trump
brand new National poll of Republicans
is that slightly more Eric cantary Eric
Cantor you can see here nobody else in
single digits all right let's go really
quickly here well we'll go back to that
right now Fox News is running their free
debate sort of package uh let's see how
they're uh how they're trying to frame
this we will stop the earmarks what is
America's role in the world we need to
build a military fitted to the widening
challenges in an Ever more dangerous
World sometimes you avoid war by showing
the tough yeah don't go without a jacket
can't eat your way out of it you can
even recognize the country in which now
live tonight candidates seeking the
Republican nomination converge in
California oh no they're doing the
fighter turn
the president Spritz them with glycerin
juice
oh my gosh that's like a Ron Burgundy I
have to expect an eagle
[Applause]
I swear I die laughing if that happened
I just found out what California all
right guys remember drinking game rules
bring them up really quickly you drink
just a full strain anytime the word
Trump is mentioned the word indictment
is used Chris Christie has a fake Tough
Guy Moment Vivek attacks anybody Rhonda
said just talks using his thumb what is
that and you finish your drink any time
someone brings up Ronald Reagan or as a
thug life moment
hey there's Nick pen pal moderators Fox
News Channel Dana Perino and Ilya
Calderon
University
oh no the first worse than Bill
superfoot Wallace the first year oh my
God
drink and tonight the first old man
white just drink because that was funny
it was funny to leave that city are we
relevant okay she's got an accent
I didn't expect that voice allow me to
welcome
speaking and welcome to America
but here we go let's welcome them in
English
so
I decided to go with a very smokey eye
this evening
two of them they are positioned by the
orders she went to the makeup artist
said do figure skater Chic I want this
dramatic
Center yes Ron DeSantis he's smelling a
fart
look at the teeth on this guy
oh Jesus token Cheshire Cat Civic okay I
don't know how she's still around I
really don't well come on look at her oh
look at the do they put a lens filter on
Tim Scott what is that yeah they did
he's back they got to put a gum filter
on
and that fat prick oh the camera adds
150 pounds hey it's a wax museum there's
four cameras on them North Dakota
governor Governor Doug burgum good
evening hide your children
[Applause]
Transylvania
primary voters candidates get one minute
to answer and 30 seconds to respond it's
singled out when their time runs out
we'll all hear this
that means drink that means
so please keep it civilized oh this
is America we needed this spacious Sunny
place tonight designed to reflect the
very nature and character of Ronald
Reagan it's a place that makes you proud
to be an American oh my God yet today
our nation is drowning in division and
incivility
three Americans think the country is on
the wrong track and three in four save
the the economy is not in good shape
prices are up 18 they're splitting the
time more than half of the U.S
population has little access to child
care 85 percent of Americans say their
personal finances are a source of stress
tonight they're going to be focusing on
the economy clue you can follow me I've
got you don't worry
President Biden is trying to do that
with bidenomics
and yesterday he joined the picket lines
where Auto Workers are demanding more
wages and job security
such as Scott you risen and less work by
Prince in spite of a successful business
model air traffic controllers in the
1980s saying you strike you're fired
would you fire thousands of striking
Auto Workers today Senator obviously the
president United States cannot fire
anybody in the private sector however we
the first Bill had 86 billion dollars
for the union pensions because they
continue to over promise yet under
deliver one of the challenges that we
have in the current negotiations is that
they want four-day French work weeks but
more money they want more
working fewer hours that is simply not
going to stand I said in a finance
committee hearing when a widow came
before the committee whose promised
pensions from from the unions before the
committee
two thousand dollars a month we must
make sure that we honor the commitments
that we make and one of the ways that we
do that do not over promise and then
under deliver and leave the tax payers
on the hook I'll say this Joe Biden
here's what you said not be on the
picket line now look these people give
to Democrats they've run these companies
into the ground you the taxpayer have
bailed them out repeatedly it's
corruption at its finest they can sink
or swim on their own
and it's not my job as president but I
tell you what I sure if it's not my job
to fire him then it's certainly not my
job to bail them out with your tax
dollars right next we must absolutely
not stop listening to advisors it
doesn't make you let it doesn't make you
unintelligent to distill things in a way
that people can unders show some passion
that's what's lit that's what's missing
in all these show some passion
Crossings since Joe Biden has taken
office and he eliminated title 42. the
one thing he should do
finish the world Tyler
ranked title 40
and gives them just the debate that
wasn't us it's going to be a close one
well you know what drink every time they
hit the Bell okay I thought I heard him
say Trump every time they hit that Bell
I think it's a Bollywood single
especially you want to talk about this
strike for just a moment more Mr Ramos
do you think she went in to the makeup
artist and said with my eyebrow give me
the Ace of Hutchinson he's not going to
be no sorry give me the what's this
shush your face she's very good with
some of what he said for sure I like the
spirit of it I'll say that I don't have
a lot of patience for the union bosses I
think that's where he and I actually
have a common view I do have a lot of
Sympathy for the workers however people
are going through real hardship in this
country I
throwing up my father stared down
layoffs at GE under Jack Welch's tenure
at the GE plant in Evendale Ohio my mom
had to work overtime in nursing homes in
Southwest Ohio to make ends meet and pay
off our home loan so I understand that
hardship is not a choice and I even had
to double it party Jimmy Neutron and we
choose to be victorious in the United
States of America you know what if I was
given advice to those workers I would
say go pick it in front of the White
House in Washington D.C that's really
where the protest needs to be disastrous
economic policies
interest rates and mortgage rates at the
same time wages remaining stagnant what
we need is to deliver economic growth in
this country unlock American energy
drill frack and this is why Donald Trump
is looming like a specter because what
they're saying is something that he's
already done wages went up an average of
five thousand dollars under Donald Trump
talking about opening up our energy
reserves like we never have before so
really their strongest talking points or
I'll do what Trump started doing until
he was cut off at the knees into three
years that is how we unleash American
exceptionalism and that's not a
democratic Vision or a republican Vision
that is an American Vision that we
Embrace economic growth and capitalism
is still the best system known to man to
lift us up from poverty and we should
not apologize for it that's what it
means to be an American
That's my boy good for him I guess it's
a drink I'm not blushing it yeah
[Applause]
makes 336 times the number of Rankin the
uh number of rank and file work by the
way later we have a seven plus one seven
plus one things that the Biden family
was doing instead of attending this
debate and uh we also have Thomas
Finnegan I should have said on the
ground at the GOP debate yeah we'll
check in with him later
last week we
hired with American workers but you also
support how these companies operate
which is it
well thank you for the question I want
to thank uh Univision
such a wonderful forum
something Tim Scott just said Joe Biden
doesn't belong on a picket line he
belongs on the unemployment line
okay Ebenezer Scrooge waiting to the
left the second leading manufacturing
estate in the country per capita I was
governor of the state of Indiana we
brought 12 000 to America during our
Administration I know something about
manufacturing he looks tired but you
can't pump gas while the union bosses
are talking about class war and how to
build a car I don't know how to spell
Clarity in wages I have to tell you I
really believe what's driving that is
bidenomics has failed wages are not
keeping up with inflation Auto Workers
and All-American workers are feeling it
and families are struggling in this
economy and Joe Biden's Green New Deal
agenda is good for Beijing and bad for
Detroit we ought to repeal the green New
Deal you know what's really bad you know
what's really bad for Detroit Detroit
yeah yeah Detroit is bad for Detroit the
soul while they're living up on Wall
Street shutting they should shut all of
it down Detroit is just as corrupt as
Wall Street and I don't care about your
Working Class Hero crap you're just
Shakedown artists in a UAW let's call it
what it is the the union workers in the
midwest do not equal American workers
they are not one of the same as a matter
of fact they have the kinds of benefits
that you could only dream of and this is
the pandering and I don't know why they
pandered in them considering that they
give 99 of their funding to Democrats
you guys can bring it up as an overlay
from open Secrets hey Tim Scott's coming
in with a holler back hey Tom Hanks
relax for me it's why we're focusing
Scott guys
and protecting the America we all love
uh
I wonder if the American
kid in
a child from the inner cities of Chicago
or the rural parts of Iowa America and
the dream it is alive it is well and it
is healthy God unlike your campaign
America did you get a sermon yes he did
a little confused can I get a witness
exactly what happened Biden showed
up on that picket line but why are those
why the housewife is talking it's
because of all understanding that he has
pushed through in the economy that's
raised the inflation so when you look at
the fact that we are paying higher gas
prices higher grocery prices seven
thousand dollars more a year for
families what we need to do is I came
out with an economic plan eliminate the
gas and Diesel tax so that they have
more money in their pocket let's focus
on on going after by the way we have
Alex Jones and I should tell you after
the debate I should have been clear we
have Alex Jones on later in the show of
course you can watch his mug Club on
Fridays look lead with passion these
people don't get it they go point to
your don't point to your plan lead with
passion the economy is not working and
it did work for years just to be clear
so obviously we need to revert back to
what was working before this guy came
into office you have eight years of
Obama you have three years of Donald
Trump like them or not you have another
two you have another two and a half
years now with Biden you're going to
have four years when it's done let's
pull it back and then recalibrate are
you guys better off that was Ronald
Reagan's question right are you better
off than you were before right don't
just point to your five point plan show
some passion that's who's gonna win this
you're mistaken these for real people
it's because Joe oh this guy's a muppet
the subsidies we're subsidizing the
automakers and we're subsidizing the
cars in a particular kind of car not
every car we're particularly we're
subsidizing electric vehicles and when
you decide that we're going to take all
of your taxpayer monies take a billion
dollars subsidize a certain type of
vehicle and the batteries come from
China China controls 85 percent of the
rare earth minerals they're called Rare
Earth because they're measured in parts
per million China is moving a hundred
thousand pounds of Earth in Indonesia in
Africa they're literally destroying the
planet so that we can they can make a
battery that's in a car subsidized here
that's too long Burger because they need
two burgers let me just point out
something to you the electric car thing
is a boogeyman it's just another example
of of course inept government but you
can go back to 2009 you can go back to
the bailout when what they would do is
they would give more money to the
American manufacturing and we can pull
this up someone can fact check me out
and I did in Detroit in Ruins they would
get give more money for any car from GM
or Ford that could get more than 30
miles per gallon whereas GM alone had
more 30 mile per gallon cars than Honda
and Toyota combined people weren't
buying them so back then the government
was subsidizing shitty cars no one
wanted but got it got gas mileage that
people didn't want they just turned that
to electric cars the point is you have
to cut the head off of the Beast yes
forcing them to make electric cars is
stupid so was forcing them to make cars
that were unsafe and got 30 miles to the
gallon call out the corrupt Union
leadership and the relationship with
Democrats they're afraid if they do it
that they'll they'll they'll lose the
midwestern working vote you just need to
delineate let's watch the fat guy
they're five trillion on and Counting
they have failed and they're in the spot
they're in now because none of them are
willing to tell the truth none of them
are willing to take on the difficult
issues they just want to keep kicking
the can down the road and the envelope
right now
and that's why people all across this
country are suffering tonight and yet
because Joe bidened with two cans of
Hormel chiliation Obama on a beach
Behind the Walls of his Gala clubs and
won't show up here to answer questions
all the rest of us are up here today
on the dead he should be in this room
that's Kristen's biggest to those
questions for the people you talk about
that's a tough guy moment and if the
government and if the government closes
and if the government closes I don't
answer to you Slither everyone in
Washington D.C who has failed to do
their job and just please to the
grandstand yeah where were you where
were you Chris Christie 52 points that's
the lead Donald Trump has on you tons of
fun I don't think he needs to answer to
you at all why but these guys look fired
up let's go to them we can get it done
he was already speaking she interrupted
him like you can speak Reckless Behavior
translator they borrow they pray they
spent and now you're paying more for
everything they are the reason for that
they have shut down our national
sovereignty by allowing our border to be
wide open so please spare me uh the
crocodile tears for these people they
need to change what's going on and
where's Joe Biden he's completely
missing in action from leadership and
you know who else is missing in action
don't say Trump Donald Trump
stage tonight Drake owes it to you to
everybody go on the stage there's
nothing a game it's two people that have
gone after that Gerald was right for the
inflation that we have this is governor
of Florida we cut taxes we ran surpluses
we've paid down over 25 percent of our
state debt and I vetoed wasteful
spending when it came to my desk and as
your president when they send me a
bloating spending bill that's going to
cause your prices to go up I'm going to
take out this veto pen and I'm gonna
send it right back to them well that's
the veto pin yeah
I know that you've been thinking about
it because child care costs they are up
there here's the thing DeSantis once you
start that now now you have to respond
when Trump attacks you in the media you
can't say I'm above it no no now you've
done you've entered into that and by the
way I respect it but you've got to be
all in now otherwise it's going to play
against you you're either all in or
you're all out it's not show friends
it's show business when you're doing
these debates but it doesn't end when
the clock runs out tonight
the given Tim's got a lot of air time
the moms and dads out there who are
worried the guy can you tell them 2.8
Congress how could you do it as
president so one of the things I did as
a member of the Congress was to make
sure that we protected the Head Start
programs around the country giving
people the opportunity to pick and
choose the place that they send their
children the challenges that we see
today under the Biden Administration is
that the cost for daycare has gone over
000 per child in the build back broker
plan he called it a buildback better
plan we get it don't explain the joke
nice guy but that's right
I don't know any brother that's not
funny
that's my point when I helped grow into
tax cuts and jobs
he's the only black guy in a foot race
who needs a Head Start program
for dual income households by 6 then we
went a step further we doubled the child
tax credit and made it refundable by
doing that more parents had more
resources to make the decisions how to
take care of their family the one thing
we should do is let the Americans get
more time yeah weighs at 2.8 so you know
he has 38 million dollars of cash on
hand come on Tim Make It Rain get some
spinners
mischaracterized a part of my view I
think this artificial division is
unhelpful in our party the real divide
is not between the Republicans on this
stage and in the Reagan Library I want
to say these are good people on this
stage
the majority of us in this country who
love the United States of America and by
the way you listen to some advisors
because you saw us polls go down a
little bit after the last debate and now
he's cozing up to them last time he was
attacking everybody and I was like
everyone here's a good guy I'm just glad
to be here how'd they go down probably
because he had the highest right after
he was yeah then he then he yeah he he
kind of had a rebound and then he went
yeah and then the mainstream media tore
my new yeah and uh you know yeah
I want to say something child care I
think billions sir you have less than
one percent shut up
I can't believe you don't shut up cut
his mic please you're always talking
with your scary eyebrows they make they
make me have to
[Laughter]
you know cut off the senator from
Transylvania
foreign
's two biggest screw-ups were him
basically opening up uh immigration the
way he did and no fault divorce in
California which he said yep but when
you run for president in 2016 you
flipped
packages where do you stand now on a
path to citizenship double down that
goes by yeah
no one has done anything since we first
had this discussion 13 years ago we're
not in a position to be able to do any
of that anymore what we have to do now
is first treat this like the law
enforcement problem it is our laws are
being broken every day at the southern
border every day and just someone just
answer yes do you think we should track
them like FedEx packages now yes and I
think you should put some makeup on your
pigment list clavicle we're gonna let it
go
and we need to have a go a president we
had one that controlled the border and
you don't like them shut up foremost and
that means
they signed an executive order to send
the National Guard and seven Hormel
chilies ago to make sure that we stop
the flow of fentanyl over the border to
make sure that we send a much different
message she's used to flow stopping his
heart decided to cut that off about
eight years ago I hate this guy I
believe if you come here to follow the
law and only if you come here legally if
you come here illegally we will
apprehend you and we will send you back
across the border from which you came
and the fact is that until we set a Law
and Order agenda in this country not
only now but in the future we won't I
will say I like his answer though I'm
going to say well it's that's
exactly what Trump did and he lost the
election so you think you're going to
win with that strategy yeah well he
didn't he didn't do enough Donald Trump
didn't do enough with the Border I don't
think well you started it though I agree
you can't do anything but this week he's
going to use the military came right out
and said it yeah so let's do it never
mind the wall we have flame throwers
like I said I eat these Hey Joe how are
you
oh hey look at that guy ah
stream of people hey buddy the country
on a daily basis in fact they believe we
have a live picture of it tonight that
is happening ice cream truck now live in
the last decade the U.S has spent nearly
55 billion dollars to address the root
causes of migration but crime poverty
and Corruption they persist and the
number of migrants is only growing are
we wasting our money yes well what
happens is when Joe Biden waved the
green flag it told everybody to come and
now we've seen six million people cross
the border we've had more fentanyl that
have killed Americans in the Iraq
Vietnam or Afghanistan Wars combined we
need to make sure that we are a country
of laws the second we stop being a
country of laws we give up everything
this country was founded on so we have
to secure the border the way we do that
is first of all defund Sanctuary cities
you see what's happening in Philadelphia
right now it's got to stop we need to
make sure we put 25 000 more border
patrol and Ice agents on the ground and
let them do their job I spent 400 miles
down that border and I'm telling you
border patrol agents aren't allowed to
do their job let's go back to remain in
Mexico policy instead of Catch and
Release let's go to catch and Deport
what about and let's see that we've been
what about the aid that federal tax
Checkers are paying to deal with the
root causes it's not working the only
Aid that we should be spending right now
is to secure the border the southern
border the northern border period
Americans safe and right now Americans
are not safe we don't like Canada
immigration system only when we get the
border secure should we ever look at
putting any more money into this our
money should be about keeping Americans
safe we're not doing that Joe Biden's
not doing that and you mentioned
Congress and and shutting down
government I'll make it clear we have to
change the budget process in four years
totally different question man 30 years
Congress has only delivered a budget on
time four times in 40 years
I'm not putting a woman in charge of
spending oh come on
how much did that top cost her come on
somebody's okay
it's the numbers game America just last
year welcome to the rich and famous
with seven countries the lifestyles of
the second tier
now include Jesus what's his problem
for 10 weeks with China deepening ties
with our Southern neighbors of course
not and the reason why we're in this
mess is because the leads in DC for far
too long have chosen surrender over
strength when it comes to the CCP some
people in our country got rich our
industrial base got hollowed out and
they have been able to swap out next
spring second most powerful military in
the entire world which is a totally new
approach to China we are going to have
real hard power in the indo-pacific like
Reagan to deter their invasions we're
going to have economic independence from
China I'm not finishing my drinking or
economy
Everyone by the way bring up the
drinking game rules again for people who
are watching right now you're supposed
to finish your drink every time they
mention Reagan I'm not gonna
yeah because let's say Trump has
mentioned yeah all right all right let's
put a Hiatus on everything Confucius
institutes so what you see a country our
powers in Decline China is going to
surpass us this decade and if they do
that that's going to affect everything
Ginger Snaps going crazy right now
you're going to choose strength not
surrender when it comes to the CCP
Americans why do you smile when he said
that he said we're going to show
strength not surrender the CCP have a
snot you were snarling when they went to
you when you were smiling when you
mentioned the CCP let's see his advisor
told him to smile the children are
citizens of the United States under what
legal premise would you expel U.S
citizens so the first thing I want to
say is I agree with everything the
Republicans on the stage that's a loaded
question and it's done if we can't expel
people in sanctuary cities who are
felons convicted felons we can't Deport
non-citizens from our prisons in certain
instances let's not talk about the dream
dreamers and the children and anchor
babies later in on that question so that
we get to the bottom of it and we can be
honest about the conversation let's go
to Jimmy Neutron uh about the
constitution in the 14th Amendment the
difference between me and them is I've
actually read the 14th Amendment what it
says is that uh attack or naturalized in
the United States and subject to the
laws and jurisdiction thereof are
citizens so nobody believes that the kid
of a Mexican Diplomat in this country
enjoys Birthright citizenship not a
judge or legal scholar in this country
is snarling now but he was smiling when
he mentioned CCP what's up with his face
he hates the Indians the kid of an
illegal migrant who broke the law to
come here and as the father of two sons
it is hard for me to look them in the
eye and say you have to find the third
one when our own government fails to
follow us that's how we really go the
distance and solve this problem and
restore I believe how much of myself
[Laughter]
[Applause]
as it relates to slavery not as it
relates to Illegal immigration it's been
applied to Illegal immigration so the
challenge that we face is in fact one
that has to do with whether or not by
the way you guys can comment we'll be
taking your chat on mug Club I think
that Donald Trump is looking at Tim
Scott for VP just my thought can I ask
why
um because he's been very complimentary
of Tim Scott and Tim Scott has been
really kind of laying off going after
Donald Trump and because he's a black
guy truly it was designed for slavery
and his black illegal immigration okay
you said that again let me go quickly
Lane the brain did come in according to
Bloomberg uh China wouldn't overtake us
until at the earliest the mid-20s 40s
and then it's only expected to be for a
minute they probably pull even and then
fall back behind us you know what I miss
I miss no longer fearing China as the
next great superpower When Donald Trump
was President it was like the paper
tiger was exposed exactly now we're back
to oh I have an uncle who works like in
finance he's like oh China is where it
is I'm going no you know I don't believe
that because they're going to have to
have a revolution at some point and
their economy is bombing right now yes
yes
all right go back to these guys they're
argument I want to respond these These
are good people who are tainted by a
broken system and it's not the fault of
anybody
no I think you should let it fly
gentlemen you'll have your turn one of
the challenges
this is what the first he gets you a
food fight
this should be all white people up there
am I right bucks
expanded into the Chinese market you
know what I did with my first company we
opened a subsidiary in China but you
know what I did would you open your call
center company
years ago
excuse me
I disagree with everyone in this room
the fact that Tim Scott is doing this a
little bit right that's his natural Let
it Fly look he just rolled his eyes he's
like no there's some that's Tim
Scott so the real Tim Scott no I agree
with that I'm saying that if Vivek wants
to win ignore him and make your point
yes but I like it I think Scott is being
a little bit more real there yeah right
let's go fans Administration canceled
they're all going after him which put
the legal status of
I forgot you were here it's like cutting
away from Macho Man Randy Savage to show
a jobber like Jean-Pierre Lafitte like
why go back to Pence
let me say I'm glad I'm glad Vivek
pulled out of his business deal in 2018
in China that must have been about the
time you decided to start voting in
presidential elections so
so let me let me speak to this ish
number one
um I negotiated to remain in Mexico
policy yeah I guess maybe you need to
hook some of your electrodes up to your
own head because you're coming across as
and gay Pence
it's just so and despite what I said
here today we reduced illegal
immigration and Asylum abuse by 90
percent and as president of the United
States I can do it again
and the truth is the truth is we need to
fix a broken immigration system and I'll
do that how many times first and
foremost a nation Without Borders is not
a nation and we have to secure the
southern border of the United States of
America and guys I'm sorry to subject
you to this
like this is useless lip service this is
the kind of crap that people don't care
about uh when we go to commercial we
have a seven plus one this is why we try
and make it entertaining for you can use
the hashtag Crowder debate night you can
get ten dollars off mug Club you get
Nick depalo every day 5 p.m Eastern you
get Alex Jones on Friday you'll get the
Hodge twins you get Brian Callan you get
our additional Friday show you'll get
you get guns and gear sorry that I
missed it you get all these things and
more like this is boring and this is
just
it's one of those things that
unfortunately you get to see it on
display that they have nothing to offer
these are empty suits this is how you
know the system is rigged and this is
why Donald Trump is ahead by more than
just basic double digits because no one
trusts these folks you don't find pent
authentic I mean I think he speaks right
from the heart he's as authentic as
Olive Garden is Italian that's right
time for on-the-job training I'm going
to be ready on day one to get Congress
to step up all right let's see the
response it sounds States build a
military fitted to other times then
we're going to get spending in
Washington DC bring up the drinking game
rules again just so people can actually
enjoy themselves tonight keep the audio
on the way do that how will these
candidates make America safer as rising
commercials
continues in moments
hey look they're they're going after
Vivek hard yeah every single one of them
I think is taking a shot at him except
for maybe one or two Count Dracula on
the end hasn't done it yet but maybe you
will we'll see yeah hold up before we
continue here uh we'll do a recap but we
actually have our correspondent uh on
the ground oh you're on the ground
correspondent Thomas Finnegan who's out
there at the GOP debate let's go to
Thomas Finnegan
foreign
[Music]
hey Finnegan what do you have for us
well it was a long drive but I made it
yeah
um why does it why does it say goop
behind you go to the goop no I said GOP
I said GOP I'm gonna go to the GOP for
the debate you're at Gwyneth Paltrow's
headquarters is
how could you be how could you have been
so wrong are you sure I'm wrong yes yes
that's goop I'm positive I just you know
what let's get you back in the road I'll
head back out we'll check back in with
you
one of those vagina candles on my way
that's disgusting let's cut them off
let's go
[Music]
really quickly a funny little meme that
was just thrown in about Pence and Vivek
here
perfect that's what it looks like
perfect the guy we don't have time for
another job training oh man so they've
they've gone after Trump right they
they've Christy and and uh uh uh Ron
DeSantis look a little too close to me a
little too in lockstep in their speeches
right I'm wondering did somebody feed
their campaigns a line on calling out
Donald Trump you know who else should be
here right now Donald Trump because they
went after Biden first he should he's
missing an action in leadership and then
Donald Trump is missing missing from
this debate they said almost the exact
same thing we have the clip of the uh do
we have the uh Donald Trump is speaking
at the UAW yeah so for those of you who
missed it we're going to check back in
with this later but again here is Donald
Trump
doing what he does tonight instead of
showing about this debate he was
speaking uh to the workers uh there at
the uh was he in Michigan or where was
he yeah I think he was there okay let's
show uh let's show a highlight of his
speech today I put everything on the
line to fight for you
I've risked it all to defend working
class from the corrupt political class
that has spent decades sucking the life
wealth and blood out of this country
that's why I'm here tonight to lay out a
vision for a Revival of economic
nationalism and our automobile
manufacturing lifelines
the whole time
hold on a future that protects America
comedy club not foreign labor
I love her he just instead of shouting
her down he just overly annunciated
manufacturers
[Applause]
manufacturing because I can't say the c
word right you know I can't say it but
that's what you uh try to read between
the lines hey look if she called me Nick
you'll be a little role player we'll do
yes and like improv let's say that you
would have referred to me as a c word I
know you are but what am I is what I
would say
winning over the Midwest under crooked
Joe Biden you have none of this you have
none of the things that takes balls to
show up there
nationalism you have Ultra left-wing
globalism they hate our country
and the workers of America
very nicely like the Dixie Chicks smoked
for a few seconds did you notice he
spoke for what a few seconds
[Music]
no idea what he was saying he didn't
know where he was
and by the way um I love that he's he's
made nationalism a good word he's
decided I'm going to co-opt it just like
fake news a lot of people don't remember
this fake news was used by the left to
try and say fake news and then he said
it's fake news he's very good at
jujitsuing that even though he doesn't
like the word because it's foreign let's
watch this uh all of the lawlessness the
shoplifting all the carjackings the
robberies they're all surging
cars were elected by their constituents
and they can't be fired by a president
so what would you do to end the
revolving door of criminality the only
one on this stage who's done it for
seven years I ran the fifth largest
office in this country at the U.S
attorney's Office
the reason was that we went after the
crime that was affected us
attorney general and it struck that
attorney general that you are to put all
the resources that are necessary to
bring our cities back under control the
fact is they will be stretched there's
no doubt about that but that's what they
take like your fans
I know oh they're making it too easy
here and not just in our cities but we
need to Law and Order back everywhere we
need to go on or back in our suburbs
people are thrilled those are cities as
well the rural areas people feel
threatened they're saying and we need it
in Washington DC also and Donald Trump
should be here
tough man from Jersey of yourself
okay and
and you're afraid of being on the stage
and Defending Your record you're ducking
these yeah that's why he's not there you
fat what is he talking
hold on hold on
we're gonna call you Donald Duck let me
tell you something though
someone give me the half and half from
the fridge because you're watching the
cream of the Crowd Oh Yeah Yeah Chris
Christie knows what he had the fifth
biggest office in the land someone give
me the cream I got a drink and I'm
losing it
oh that's a real ass cream from the
fridge now
by the way I will have I know what
you're thinking I will have a pineapple
outside of my I will hotel tonight
I had two Progressive prosecutors that
weren't following the law in Florida I
removed them from their posts and the
people I like Rhonda I do too but look I
do too you do right now what are you
speaking with his thumb
is Crowder debate night you get ten
dollars off at lotto.com none of this
happens if not for Mud Club
variety and disorder
again yes we are also taking predictions
by the way on Twitter I use the hashtag
Crowder debate that just said that
because he wanted to show the card
between yeah yeah I haven't shown the
card yet three years ago you signed a
pledge to support law enforcement now
pledges are a nice idea but what's your
actual plan to get more police on our
streets why are you in your bathroom
well and I actually did it in South
Carolina too you know Trump responded to
them
uh see if he's responding on truth to uh
okay he's taking care of them with words
they do right now we have a lot of
stolen guns on the street well these
largest monsters professional wrestling
Trump's going to come in as Steve Austin
I'll tell you you got this
right here he's you want to reach down
to the bottom of
you go lift up that Barrel you end up
with Chris Christie okay
tell you what I'm going to do here Chris
Christie trying to talk about me saying
I have I'm gonna drink every one of
these beers right here and I'm
not going to listen to a damn word you
say what because I do what I said I will
do
[Laughter]
antibiotic that we need he's got green
brother Company in Bristol Tennessee
that produces that yet our federal
government only gets it from China we
need to be focusing on companies that
produce in America and supporting those
companies that produce in America not
company Christmas throw rug jackets
we'll be talking foreign policy later
thank you um Stuart we're going to say
the topic of a crime because
it affects I come from a country but
there's a lot of it for the first as a
matter of fact there is more crime than
no crime and gun safety in the middle of
the day if you go to a stoplight and
it's red you're going to get hit it is
the opposite it's like Simon says but if
someone doesn't say you commit crime
it's your specific plan to curb the
place well first we need to notice to
understand is I think that the liberal
left is seems to be just hold on a
second Prosecuting law-abiding citizens
that are gun owners because every
solution they have to this is take away
the Second Amendment rights of Americans
and somehow that's going to solve the
problem but all these cities was that
we're talking about that showed the
videos of tonight they have some of the
strictest gun laws in the country so we
know that that's not what's working but
we have to do is get back to the core
issue the family these are all nice
people I like what they say it's like
about like let's say a Rush Limbaugh
right someone who's just legendary
versus someone who's one of those let's
say social media conservative sites
where it's like this is the weekend wrap
up and it's a bunch of conservative
talking points that's the difference
there's a there are levels to this game
here's what I want you to think of when
you watch a guy like this okay what
sport did you play any of you play a
sport let's say it's basketball let's
say it's hockey pretty good okay I want
you to think of the best person you know
at that sport let's say it's basketball
let's say it's football think of the
best person you've ever competed with
how far did they go now you're probably
not offended at that why because they
probably worked a lot harder than you
right they probably spent all day
practicing and preparing well they were
black now here's yes here's what we have
black uh we have like we have a black
viewer now I want you to think of the
difference between your level and the
level of that person now think of the
difference between the level of the best
person at the sport that you played that
you know
and let's say an NBA All-Star or let's
say someone who made it to the first
round draft right at the NFL now you
have the NBA All-Stars compare that to
LeBron or Michael Jordan or a Tom Brady
there are levels to this game and you're
going in with someone at that level
Donald Trump this isn't enough you have
to make up for it with grit this won't
work let's see what Vivek might try he's
doing the white supremacist symbol
remember that was the white supremacist
I know well he also Burns a cross in
front of his Podium but you know for the
love of God they lost their son
Sebastian 17 years old he bought
Percocets Snapchat and then he died why
did he die because it was laced with
fentanyl that is closer to bioterrorism
well let's be honest the fender was a
bonus if he was buying Percocet on
Snapchat but he died it wasn't like he
wasn't looking for it he just had too
much I'm just tired of everyone making
just fentanyl the boogeyman like I get
it of course you shouldn't be taking any
street drugs because fentanyl could be
in it but they try and make it seem like
kids are getting addicted to fentanyl
because they had a Percocet from a root
canal it's a third it's a third rail no
one wants to say that the opioid
epidemic is something that politicians
don't want to actually address and
doctors now can't prescribe painkillers
to people who have been in car wrecks I
have a theory about this yeah because it
is becoming so dangerous Percocet
whatever it's not though it's fentanyl
it's street drugs no no I'm saying but
but
these drugs that aren't street drugs the
lace with this crap yeah eventually I
would think as as our youth is
in this country they're going to be like
I'm not doing drugs anymore long term at
some point at some point it's like
there'll be 11 kids left it's like
double dare huh but I'm saying yeah
eventually you're going to know somebody
who knows somebody or yeah everybody's
going to know somebody and yeah I don't
know let's see what the Santa says to go
after the Mexican drug cartels they are
killing our people the military stories
hey don't talk about my brother it's
been 18 months parents rented an Airbnb
and apparently the people that had
rented before were using drugs oh yeah
by the way this iliac Calderon she said
that Trump's rhetoric empowers white
supremacists so I guess it empowers that
little spot in her neck what is she
doing on the panel happen this Carnage
Fox News
I guarantee you on day one this border
is going to be a day one issue for me as
president we're going to declare it a
National Emergency yes we'll build the
wall we'll do remain in Mexico but those
Mexican drug hotels are going to be
treated like the foreign
however you also made that same promise
in 2016. whoops and at that time Trump
Pence had Congressional majorities for
at least the first two years and and you
did not deliver on that promise so
Obamacare right now it is more popular
than ever
some president to fix that or is
Obamacare here look at his smug face I'm
sorry I know well first let me speak to
the mass shootings issue and then I'll
answer that question it's important one
Dana he always says well first let me
thank you first let me speak first let
me go
father of three is the grandfather of
three beautiful little girls
tired of these mass shootings happening
in the United States of America if I'm
president of the United States I'm going
to go to the Congress and hold the
shootings to Mexico we're going to pass
a federal expedited death penalty for
anyone involved in a mass shooting
definitely does so much to stop crime
right now it is a deterrent it's not but
he's not going to be able to get a
federal death penalty on that no it's
just not even everything you notice at
Pence comment do you notice that Pence
picks the solutions that obviously can
never be implemented he picks them just
because it's something that no one can
call him on did you just request a
tissue is your nose is your nose are you
upset I just I might cry by the way
here's you know what a gangbanger has
never done hey
stop man you could get the death penalty
dang it yeah that's right I'm sorry or
mentally nobody has done that a mentally
ill kid yeah shooting up the school oh
it's true I mean I'm still Pro death
penalty but yeah I'm Pro death penalty
but thank you Mike Pence for giving us
something that is going to do nothing to
stop the violence in he's like a guy at
a party who's two drinks in who acts
like he has an inside Lane like hey look
Nick
you know how you stop mastering this in
this country
I got two words for you death penalty
here first you got it I'm kidding here
you look at him
[Music]
Elite Gifford yeah exactly
I don't know what that means but I feel
like it's accurate I do too I went with
it all right let's see everyone to keep
within that time frame so that we can
get as many questions please shut the
hell up Governor DeSantis over 26
million Americans
two and a half million of them are in
your state am I right that's worse than
the national average can Americans trust
you on this well I think this is a
symptom of our overall economic decline
everything has gotten more expensive you
see insurance rates are going through
the roof people that are going to get
groceries I spoke with a woman in Iowa
and she said you know for the first time
in my life I'm having to take things out
of my grocery cart when I get to the
checkout line because the the total goes
up so quickly so this is very real and
people are hurting I said to her like so
you've got to address she couldn't come
up with anything she was a liar
we need more lie detectors in Krogers it
will lower your gas prices
our health care is putting patients
how much for eggs
our state's a dynamic State we've got
we've got a lot of folks that come of
course we've had a population boom we
also don't have a lot of welfare
benefits in Florida you know we're
basically saying we want to this is a
Field of Dreams you can do well but
we're not going to be like California
and have massive numbers of people
um on government programs without work
requirements we believe you work and you
got to do that and so that goes for all
the work and you know what that's done
Stuart our unemployment rate is the
lowest amongst any big state we have the
highest GDP growth events any big state
and even CNBC no fan of mine rank
Florida the number one economy in
America
but that one's at least that was good
that made sense it's like the bridge
sent the signal to his mouth
Americans
who get sick from Financial ruin first
of all how can we be the best country in
the world and have the most expensive
Health Care in the world we have an
issue my mom was in the hospital and
when she was there the giant handout
that was Obamacare to insurance
companies this is one thing that Donald
Trump does relatively well a lot of
people don't realize this okay so
Obamacare said you cannot deny people
for pre-existing conditions I understand
that that sounds good to a lot of people
because I say you know I have pre-exist
I have let's say I have cancer let's say
if you're a millennial you're a gen Z
you have generalized anxiety or acne and
you can't get insurance because of that
so you can't be denied for pre-existing
conditions however there is nothing to
tell the insurance companies that they
had to put a cap on it so now they have
to accept every single person who by the
way they decided to cut out of their
insurance pool because insurance is
something you're supposed to buy
preemptively right because you'll be
costly coming with a pre-existing
condition and they decided to they
decided to add those costs to everyone's
insurance plan insurance companies never
made more money they never saw the
biggest year-to-year increase they never
saw a bigger sorry year to year increase
than after Obamacare and it was all done
under the guise of you by the way the
people getting the 50 million murder
they used to cite that number of
uninsured when a large number of those
people were people who chose to not be
injured because they were young and
healthy talk about the handouts to the
insurance industry and tie it to Pfizer
and moderna with the vaccine I don't
know why they don't do it sorry we have
to go back to Varney and the lady and
why not the real problem ever we talk
about why do we have oh Jesus
because the federal government got
involved this is the silliest thing I've
ever done it's a question
I've been to a doctor's office
lights on a keyboard and by the way his
suit jacket it doesn't help is so short
and the sleeve is so long yes
they saw less patience per day is U.S
healthy because of their responsibility
I hate the way you look why wouldn't you
born in a Jim Henson Creature Shop
it's involved whether it's higher
education Healthcare but also bring up
the uh uh what's his name Oscar the
Grouch yeah yeah
control room give me the average cost
for an MRI in the United States real
quick what's the government's role in
finding a way forward the second
Republican debate rolls on from Simi
Valley
[Music]
teaching our children what America is
and what she represents in the long
history of the world
really quickly here all right so they
gave me that average cost of an MRI is
1325 you know why insurance I went to a
place that doesn't take insurance
doesn't need you to have a doctor send
that in they got me in within an hour on
a Saturday and I think it cost me 375
dollars cash whoa I have one better than
that I blew out my back when I was
working for Fox News in New York don't
say you have one better that was pretty
good that's pretty good I'm sorry I
didn't mean to top you by the way the
promo code is I'll be taking your chat
so I blew out my back remember they had
to cut off my pants because I lost all
motor function in my leg then the yeah
then the male nurse shoved his finger up
my ass to chat they do that to check to
see if you have any damage to see you
know to your lower spine yeah right and
you had fingers like Polish sausages but
they misread the MRI they read the wrong
MRI the chairman of Lenox Hill Hospital
in Manhattan because I couldn't go home
they sent me home they said you're fine
I couldn't walk home I had to have an
intern from Hannity take me home and
help me change my pants they said sorry
you got the wrong MRI uh uh let's just
check oh you don't have insurance I
didn't at this time and they said sorry
the twelve thousand dollar bill it's 250
paid at boom I was good to go yeah Steve
I went to the same doctor that wasn't a
finger
[Applause]
you are you a doctor I thought it was
Sebastian delmonic uh I thought it was
Stella well it prevents us all right do
you have to go to it that's the problem
no okay we're good right all right let's
go to uh is the first commercial break
that we're going to go to is it is there
BTS there is that what we're talking
yeah okay we have a lot of BTS real so
we are going to be uh back here with you
and I have to go uh use the bathroom we
will not miss any of the debate keep it
up in the lower third while the uh while
the break keeps rolling and uh you know
we have these shows on Friday sometimes
we can see what happens behind the
scenes with all these sketches
everything going on with the show and uh
you know sometimes it's the kind of
thing that should never make air and the
entire thing is the YouTube dump button
so we're continuing with the debate in
about 30 seconds
experiences
deep within
listening anyone here ever uses out and
touch your pecker yeah yeah sorry Molly
the many that Nick de Paulo saw in my
raw Shack test stuff
that's perfect I can't top that I
invited him to pleasure my
availed himself with great Vigor in zeal
you don't have like purple rings under
your eyes
which doesn't change it cannot be what
happens to you
is this from trolls four
[Music]
oh
everybody loves Joe Lewis so Stephen so
I got an idea all right so here's to
check this out so it's like a house
party right kids hanging out getting
loose you know maybe just people hanging
off the sides of stairs right suddenly a
guy walks in says hey you want to try
this CB Distillery tincture yeah see the
problem with that is the implication is
that they're inebriated this is the
sponsor CB distilleries it's CBD it's
the opposite no one you don't get high
it's anti-psychoactive okay well let me
finish yeah it's got more yeah so then
everyone tries it
and then everyone gets really high yes
no got no gosh for Chris Joe can you
jump in here okay fine look so here
here's here's the pitch right so this is
a hard-working father right he's in the
boardroom we've got like pictures of him
at the restaurant a montage of him
walking in the city like skyscrapers in
the background right you following me he
comes home drops his briefcase he's
loosening up his tie
and then he lines up a CB Distillery
cigarette and passes out in his kids
room chill YouTube no no this is CBD
okay it doesn't get you high
stress anxiety can help with
inflammation it's anti-inflammatory it
can help you with some pain after
exercise okay exercise all right I got
one we gotta check this out all right
football player just got done training
for the day right okay so he's gonna sit
down and wants to ice his knee so he's
going to reach into his bag he's going
to grab some of this uh what is it CBD
relief stick yeah right he's gonna start
to apply it on himself okay and suddenly
starts realizing how big his hands are
getting and how heavy his feet are no
maybe he gets hungry no it's not
psychoactive it's CBD you don't get high
it's anti-inflammatory it's actually
anti-psychotic
they have third party lab tests all the
Sciences there on their website it
basically sells itself am I gonna have
to write this on my own
yeah yeah you should but we can edit it
wait are we filming are we filming it
right now
Steven's not here man go to
cbdiscillary.com enter the promo code
Crowder for up to 60 off whoa
[Music]
Cody what are you doing man oh I'm
trying the new pudding for my all right
well hold on you could transition a
little bit yeah it could have been
crying out loud
hey by the way really quickly because we
have very few sponsors but we do them
often with these live streams it's CB
Distillery it's actually 60 off yeah it
helped your neck by the way it did a
little bit and helped my neck quite a
bit just so I mean licking that who knew
there's a lot of actually there's a lot
of scientific research on CBD
specifically with neuropathic pain I was
you know in third chair last week you
may not know this because I couldn't
move my neck after using the CB
Distillery and by the way after surgery
I use their stuff keep it in the lower
third always there uh to a man that you
can't please be a debate
um after surgery I was able to use it
and uh able to the only thing they had
me taking was Gabapentin so no narcotics
um and the CBD helped a lot by the way
if you take the full spectrum CBD which
you should you will test positive on a
drug test because there's you know less
than 0.3 THC so
just so you know and pull that lower
third I was doing a life insurance
policy they're like What's this the deal
got better it's not just 20 60 up to 60
off that's fantastic let's go to the
Rockefeller Christmas tree Nikki Haley
States and let States decide what
education looks like in their states and
we need to start building things in
America again let's put vocational
classes back in our high schools and
let's get our kids let's put you back in
finishing school when we start to focus
on that and really bring in that
parental involvement that's when we'll
start to see a difference but we've got
to get parents back included we've got
to quit spending time on this Dei is
Nick de Paul is the most clever man I've
ever met in my life and it's silly
stupid that makes them laugh oh
yeah why is she in a hockey rink
foreign
cards but minorities are not doing well
with math and reading
students averaging 29 Points lower I
want to see some honesty yeah they're
stupid jerseys
I'm not saying I don't believe that no
you have to address all students and
look in our state Steward frankly
carbohydrates come first that Gap was
close to 50 and what we did was
Institute more charter schools and more
Renaissance schools and more public
school choice in New Jersey
we took what was the worst school
districts in America during my time and
we have now increased that by nearly 40
percent in terms of their proficiency it
can be done when you give people a
choice
but hey if you're really upset with that
jokes with Christy can you let us know
again you can comment if you like the
just you know you can you can also
comment or hit the like button on
YouTube or on Rumble we're children as
Nick depalo and by the way somebody
complaining you should tune into a show
everybody whining it who's the
funniest no no this is the funniest
ever problem okay come on come on man
come on 5 p.m Eastern I can't tell you
how I am okay sorry every day
for the worst of their teachers
a president United States is to take on
the teachers union I did it in New
Jersey and I will do it speaking of
Jersey mics
[Laughter]
says quote slaves develop skills which
in some instances could be applied for
their personal benefits
many are he's probably gonna have a
strong answer here for the sentence this
is personal what is your message
bring up the drinking game rules by the
way for everyone who's watching right
now Crowder debate night anytime he
talks with his thumb you drink let's go
back to stop playing these games
our country's education system is in
decline because it's focused on anything
kick out the Chinese kids
good night everybody it's the Revival of
American Education
number one in education by U.S news and
World Report my wife and I we have a six
five and three-year-old this is personal
to us we didn't just talk about
universities
[Laughter]
then I moved to South Carolina
's kid what are you talking about in our
schools in a really big way just he can
ask for in his farewell address back in
1989. Florida is showing how it's done
we're standing with parents and our kids
are benefiting okay thank you
[Applause]
that's tracheotomy redeeming quality in
slavery he and Kamala should have just
taken the one sentence out
America
America has suffered because of slavery
but we
believe in seconds on Earth no I think
this is good though he's using a jumping
off point I like him in his ass so often
we think that all the issues you talk
about crime and Education Health Care we
always that's the way those issues go
back to slavery here's the challenge
though family survive slavery we
survived poll taxes and literacy tests
we survived discrimination being woven
into the laws considering your word
whiskers tonight that remains to be seen
affirmative action Great Society where
they decided
to put money
or they decided to take the black father
out of the household to check in the
mail and you can now measure that and
unemployment and crime
if you want to restore hope you drink
his milk tonight he's coming in he's
getting a little look this is the real
Tim Scott I want him to show the real
Tim Scott early on he wasn't the last
time I said there's no boring black
people no there are no they woke up
tonight there you go right direction
it's why I can say I have been
discriminated against but America is not
a racist country never ever doubt Who We
Are we are the greatest country on God's
green earth and frankly all of a sudden
he gets hit with a full Heineken he
needs a brand new leader with the
moderator Corona coronavent alignment
over 10.7 million dollars and over 18
000 Public Schools Northern borders open
it could hit with a Clamato their
identity without parental notifications
Governor Christie told Stewart last week
that he would pass a federal law to
protect parental rights he looks like a
tough guy Vivek looks like the actor if
he was brown who played the mayor of
Gotham in the Dark Knight bring him up
you'll see what I'm talking about
Gary old Gary Oldman no no no the mayor
oh yeah yeah yeah okay get the most
powerful
the right to know and you know what the
hypocrisy they were wrong even New
Hampshire failed to actually get past a
piece of legislation here
and then Tim Scott said get a piece of
ass come on yeah
it is not compassionate to affirm a
kid's confusion
that is cruelty two young women Chloe
and Katie early in this campaign who are
in their 20s
double mastectomies and the hysterectomy
one of them will never have children
it has to happen in this country
barbaric so I will ban genital
mutilations
parents should have that
states absolutely have to follow
child
you say parents have that right
this is a state's issue but let me just
say this because all night long we've
been talking about how it's broken
in my house
he's got an Italian nose he's a German
guy it's Martin scorses he being a
problem North Dakota because we have a
business leader I've got more 90 of
Voters don't know who he is or that he
is running for president
thousands of high-paying jobs
he's not even going to sell books
bring up overlay 04.
90 of Voters don't know who Doug burgum
is just yet well holding out hope yep
really how do you get into the debate
there's a chance
okay one of the murdoches
yes we have 50s platforms of innovation
that's why we have states there are
certain things the federal government is
supposed to do I'm making fun of a guy
as a multi-azillion and that needs to be
assembled we've got to move all right do
it like I said great to be here there's
a choice School in here's an old school
thank you Diane kids are trapped and by
the way everyone Innovation and or send
a comment and for everyone who makes
this happen here behind the scenes right
the drinks they help with the research
they do and even though Mr Mark's here
is he'd have a better chance if he just
started singing like Billy Joel's moving
out just anything just any just anything
just pick up where you left off last
time they cut you off
vice president Pence the Department of
Homeland Security warns that violence
against lgbtq plus people is on the rise
according to a study
again Trump
[Music]
foreign
guys made a Knotty Pine and when I was
driving the state of Indiana we doubled
it and I see your question Daniel let's
let's be very well that's his biography
finally The Place Beyond the Knotty
Pines
a dirt bike behind him in a bank heist
permission slip from your parents to get
a Tylenol but you could get a gender
transition plan without notifying your
parents I weighed in with a foundation
that's a flight waste that's crazy
they put them in a Free Willy hammock
and had to break down his North
walled in on the issue and then I went
to a uh Shell station I was dumbfounded
what are you say again about that Chris
Christie
oh my goodness
with the ability to choose where their
kids go to school
parochial or High School you Empower
parents and our schools will straighten
up and reflect everything look can can
you guys let me know if you disagree
here everything with him has a platitude
it's not really a specific you embolden
parents right oh you're absolutely right
okay I agree with you in principle Mike
Pence but this is your opportunity to
let people know how you're going to make
a difference this guy is just a
professional coattail Rider let's watch
uh Lifestyles of the Rich every year on
semi Liberace gold toilet that is one
one per year
Governor DeSantis you say companies like
Google and meta have too much power yes
this is important half of them give
China an edge
no I think you look at how our societies
develop they have huge amount of power
over our society they've cracked down on
Free Speech uh we're not saying you know
give me a specific which you want it to
be section 230 what are you going to do
this is this affects everybody
especially with Rumble right now in
international governments give me a
specific uh we have subcontracted out so
much of our national needs to the CCP we
rely on them for a whole host of issues
we need to reassure and we need to
decouple all those important industries
we need to get that back in the United
States they are our top geopolitical
adversary by a country mile Gigi Ping's
got huge Ambitions not only Google meta
section 230. will you revoke their
status as a public utility But
ultimately we've got to beat them on the
economy and so that's what we'll do is
probably in the United States Governor
Christie I wanted to up on this because
22 percent of American workers fear
their jobs will be lost to a robot and
you said look look I'm sorry this is the
reason
that's all Fox gives them on the the
biggest issue of our time right social
media these Tech Giants five companies
control everything that you see in here
we're experiencing it right now not only
yours truly Russell Brand by the way of
course you've seen what's happened with
Rumble you literally have the UK
Parliament telling Rumble that they are
going to ban them by the way they were
already banned by the French government
at one point they flipped them the bird
these people have more power than World
they have more power than think of this
the Senate when you're going back to
Rome think about that for a second and
they skim past it why well because Fox
is newscorn by the way they spend
billions of dollars advertising on Big
Tech every year so they want to keep
that Stranglehold this is that sort of
coordinated professional wrestling when
you have CNN Turner you've got uh or is
it ABC Disney NBC Universal news core
they don't really want to lose the
foothold that they have on YouTube that
they have on Facebook and Instagram so
they don't want to ask these they don't
these questions and push too hard it's
the most important issue that affects
every single one of you right now if you
search this show Stephen Crowder changed
my mind abortion you will find something
else likely from news core or PBS
that's why by the way head on over to
rumble later with credit.com we do not
take a dime on YouTube from advertisers
there we can't
and we chose not to we can't no no no we
were allowed to at one point and we said
you know what no we're not going to
self-censor no that's all they get the
most important issue of our time
imagine right now if you were to go out
into a Town Square before the internet
and if you were to start speaking and
they arrested every single one of you
that's what's happening with big Tech
and they get one question and then move
on to the CCP there is no issue that is
more important you lose your voice you
lose everything
my God Fox News so the answer is I have
a radical idea for the Republican party
we need to win elections and part of how
we win elections is reaching the next
generation of Young Americans where they
are so when I get into office I've been
very clear kids under the age of social
under the age of 16 should not be using
enough media we're only going to ever
get to declaring independence from China
which I favor if we actually win so
while the Democrats are running rampant
reaching the next generation three to
one there's exactly one person in the
Republican party which talks a big game
about reaching young people and that's
me and let me level with all of you I
talk a big game yeah that's not a
positive that's like you know there's
one person here who uh that's right and
that's me a bit of a know-it-all it
seems at times I'm here to tell you you
didn't lose the last election okay do
they all believe you lost best people
the best and brightest in this country
whatever age they are advising me no
there will be probably many of the
people on the street that's trying to
reach out to these people they hate you
I want you and you can't reach out to
them unless you change section to look
this is the rigged game and I'm telling
you this with conservatives across the
board they don't want to run up because
if you talk about 230 you end up like us
where you end up on Rumble and you end
up being suspended on YouTube and
demonetizing it's a game of cat and
mouse all of them want those dollar
dollar bills from Big Tech and until any
of them grow the balls to speak up
against it it is a rigged game and it is
professional wrestling it is Kabuki
theater that is the most important issue
period and all of them have sidestepped
is it me
except for Trump and he's crushing well
yeah exactly so there you go Nikki Haley
let's see that means they can get your
contacts they can get your financial
information they can get your email and
thank you
this is
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
all of those people are the same people
it's a revolving door all right the
country is being invaded we don't even
got to defend the American people before
we even worry about all these other
things and I watch these guys in
Washington DC and they don't care about
the American people they don't care
about the fentanyl deaths they don't
care about the communities being overrun
because of this border they don't care
about the Mexican drug cartels so as
commander-in-chief I will defend this
country sovereignty it's been pretty
strong he's absolutely right about it
that's the number one issue yeah who
cares about the economy they don't have
a country he's done more on the
immigration issue than probably anyone
on that stage and so he has a leg to
stand on he is alone it is not 90 of the
money that we send over there is loan
well we can talk about this but at the
end of the day 90 of the money that we
send over there is actually it's not
actually not be paid by Ukraine it's
paid by the NATO or NATO allies
I will say let's let's debate the fact
just say what you want to say nobody's
going to stop for you vital interests is
in degrading the Russian military by
degrading the Russian military we
actually keep our homeland safer we keep
our troops at home and we all understand
Article 5 of NATO with the American
people I thought you said something
about waiting until don't listen to him
they didn't wait for you I'm going to
finish my I'll be happy to do that I'll
respond I'll look forward to this one
right now um so at the end of the day
when you think about the fact if you
want to keep American troops at home
attack on NATO territory would bring us
and our troops in by degrading the
Russian military we reduce if not
eliminate sorry is NATO
no did I miss something but NATO is has
an interest in defending Ukraine and so
therefore what is Ukraine NATO no no
okay it's not and Putin's an evil
dictator does not mean that Ukraine is
good this is a country that has banned
11 opposition parties
come on on come on Vivek this is a
strong point for you these people are so
tone deaf on the stage they don't know
the vast majority of Americans do not
want money going to Ukraine go visit go
join me they're into China's arms we
need a reasonable peace plan to end this
especially if this is a country whose
president just last week
Ukraine that's a green light to China to
take Taiwan we need a peace that comes
through strength get another talking
point Mike Pence maybe someone will hear
you and they're not even his talking
point they're from 1980s the president
Governor Christie President Biden's
first two years
Russia and Iran together I only focus
too much on Ukraine and not enough on
this threat from the New World Order no
they're all connected Stuart they're all
connected
the Chinese are paying for the Russian
war in Ukraine the Iranians are
supplying more sophisticated weapons and
so are the North Koreans now as well
with the encouragement of the Chinese
the naivete on the stage from some of
these folks is extraordinary look I
understand people want to go and talk to
Putin guess what so did George W bush
so did Barack Obama
go to Donald Trump and so did Joe Biden
when he said a small Invasion wouldn't
be so bad every one of them has been
wrong
and the fact of the matter is freaking
game roles
right now
that the Chinese Russian Alliance is
something we have to fight against and
we are not going to solve it by going
over and cuddling up to Vladimir Putin
look Donald Trump said Vladimir Putin
was brilliant drink and a great
leadership this is the person who is
murdering people in his own country and
now not having enough blood he's now
going to Ukraine by the way can we fact
check that I'm pretty sure that Donald
Trump said that about Putin again what
he did say was that he said Putin is not
an idiot he said Putin is a smart person
right by the way Hitler was an evil man
he was a smart man just to be clear uh I
would say Stalin not all that bright
Lenin was pretty bright and an evil
person I'm pretty sure that President
Donald Trump said that before Chris
Christie supported him just to be clear
and now he's trying to act as though oh
I've been the I've been a moral con uh
continual the voice of reason you're
going to really like or at least you
have experience in it and we need to
talk about America's Farmers because
there is a foreign policy connection
here the US and China to Farmers and
talk about subsidies it's hurting
American businesses and there is blow
against American farmers because China
then targets them it
would U.S president protect American
farmers and ranchers from that kind of
retaliation from a foreign government
like China well first of all we've got
the best farmers and ranchers in the
world right here in America if they have
a Level Playing Field they can
out-compete anyone in the world but this
is part of the larger issue that we're
talking about here which is we're in a
cold war with China the Biden
Administration won't admit that but
we're also in a economic War through the
what we're doing with Agriculture and
energy and we're also in a war with them
relative to something about China buying
up American Farmland in North Dakota
every state every school district our
tribes all being attacked every day by
either China Russia Iran or North Korea
and now we've got a Biden Administration
whose whole policy is appeasement
they're out there you know creating the
world making less safe six billion
dollars they traded for five people
they've just now set a price on anyone's
head who's a tourist from America who's
a student from America for kidnapping if
you want more kidnapping put a price on
it and then that's and they're also
helping Iran get to have more closer to
nuclear weapon than which pushes all of
the middle
behind and ninety percent of Americans
not knowing who you are Groucho is that
you have to fit every talking point into
every single answer so he's not able to
give one clear Lucidity right he's not
wrong in anything he's saying but it's
just it's too much getting drowned out
because nobody knows who this guy is and
by the way I want to make sure that we
clarify you said it correctly just to
give a little bit more context Donald
Trump was talking about when he went
into Ukraine and when he went into the
eastern part and said hey we're just
going to go in and we're going to keep
the peace and he's like wow that's
pretty Savvy that's not talking to his
morals that's talking to his strategy
his strategy worked yeah he is where he
took Crimea he's taken vast swaths of
eastern Ukraine and the world hasn't
stopped him I mean he's paying a price
for it but the guy is smart the guy is
Savvy he's getting what he wants so far
that's what he was referring to Mark
Zuckerberg's not an idiot and I think
he's evil I don't know why people feel
as though they have to they have to lie
about that let's watch Miss pigment
OS
Mexico is a United States most important
trade partner
and border security
you say you will send Special Operations
to attack the cartels in Mexico so this
means boots on the ground
drone strikes
it means Special Operations it's how we
deal with our terrorists and what you
need to do is understand that Mexico is
not being a good partner
Mexico's not being a good partner if
they're letting the cartels get away
with what they're getting away with what
we will do is we will make sure that we
send in our special operations and we
will take out don't you love how these
people
volume but we're gonna go after China
because China is the one sending the
fentanyl in the first place and we will
end all normal trade relations until
China stops
absolute lie you will not do that I
don't care if they're sending over
enough to kill a hundred thousand
reasons a day you will not end right
relations with China you're not going to
do it if you go by body mass of the
Chinese it's 250 000 but yes the fact
that they were stealing 600 billion you
notice they try and take everything to
fentanyl that's why it's it's that whole
like hey Boogeyman yeah it's a slate of
hand it's like hey fentanyl fentanyl
Fentanyl and so they they don't want you
to actually look at the facts they're
not answering look someone should just
say this screw Mexico okay we'll talk
about the CCP we'll talk about fentanyl
Mexico doesn't care about you their
government is corrupt for crying out
loud these people aren't doing a damn
thing we're not going to work with
Mexico until they clean up their own
country and by the way look at their
immigration policies if you're not a
natural born Mexican citizen you can't
vote you can't own waterfront property
for crying out loud they all suck we're
better that's why we don't do business
with them until they start cleaning up
their act yeah and by the way Mexico
where's your Revolution the cartels are
in control of your country you you guys
really want a better country we're we
paid with blood it sucks but you have to
do it and by the way I'm Nikki Haley I'm
sorry you're not going to send in
Special Forces and solve the problem we
will send in U.S Special Forces and we
will stop we will take out these cartel
leaders you know how many times we've
done that do you have many times the
cartel leaders have been taken out
the forces aren't the people they have
to worry about it's rival cartel leaders
because there's always another person
ready to take over you would have
stopped the problem Zero by doing that
but thank you very much for playing this
game I thought you knew foreign policy
yeah and I don't dislike Nikki Haley I
just think it's a really stupid she's
afraid she doesn't want her head to end
up on a turtle let's hear Tim Scott
Relations Committee also on the finance
committee and the Banking Committee talk
about addressing the issue of fentanyl
I've written the legislation past
through the bank ing committee and the
Senate that would freeze the assets and
sanction the accounts of the Mexican
cartels there are weapons that we have
within the Arsenal that I have ways
around them three to zero and what do
they keep this money forever cartels
they have their money at the savings
they're not W-2 employees oh exactly El
Chapo keeps his money and Luxembourg
yeah intelligence that was available by
the way I'm sorry guys I need a refill
because DeSantis kept talking with his
thumb
it's key to making sure that we prevent
the next 911 from ever happening having
that they're planning that right now by
the way it's in Newark really important
in getting the job seriously they're
here at the airport they're going to
take out a sparrows
well I think you asked the question but
exactly they do that I'll enlist
I love that you drunken walked on you
greasy stereotype you you imitating a
president or the fire and all of our
voices
for those of us that have the experience
have a special set of skills the tested
experience and a commitment that Ronald
Reagan brought forward in this party of
a strong National Defense standing with
our allies standing up to her supporting
limited government
this is something that advisors teach
you they say don't point because it
feels accusatory so use your thumb like
we don't know
most consistent conservative in this
field and I'm ready to lead America at
home and abroad on days well we're not
ready for you to do how about that
yeah I want your master the
super unleaded we'll let you know
any of these candidates do the same
we'll take that up when the debate
continues I have to go pee pee okay well
well then I guess uh let's uh you know
what I can wait you can well I can wait
I think it's time for uh because the
bidens actually we've gotten word are
not watching tonight's debate really and
you can use a promo code Crowder debate
night you get ten dollars off Mud Club
by the way we will do no more of these
if there is no Mud Club so all the free
content exists only because of the
people who support Mud Club you get
Nick's show every day 5 p.m you get
Brian Callan you get the Hodge twins
they're starting their show here in
October you get Alex Jones on Friday uh
and uh it allows us to do the kinds of
things that would never be permissible
on YouTube
um
like we always have the inside Lane we
do yeah yeah the binds are not watching
tonight's debate they are not and
they're doing other things which brings
us to tonight's seven plus one
foreign
in the chamber
oh shoot my divider and my thing
all of a sudden one plus one list hold
on a second you have your lit you have
your list there uh hold on Nick right
there he's got your setlist what
happened face I lost my oh right okay
this is tonight's seven plus one I I
appreciate it I just broke my whole
thing I do you know what by the way uh N
I do need this stapled
all right it's a commercial break keep
bash that keep the lower third up there
two minutes of people know this is uh
seven plus one things the Biden family
is doing instead during the GOP debate
number seven Divine family is playing
Guess Who with the Biden family tree
[Laughter]
uh number six seven plus one things that
the Biden family is doing instead of
watching The GOP debate uh
they're busy ignoring their seventh
granddaughter
that's number six
seven plus one things the Biden family
is doing instead of watching this debate
number five Nick de Paulo Hunter is busy
banging his dead brother's widow oh
yummy wow you know what hey the
refractory period is impressive
foreign
Gerald seven plus one things the Biden
family is doing during the GOP debate
number four filling out ballots for
2024. oh well that makes sense that's
the hanging yeah crack pipe chat
[Laughter]
number three Joe is dragging his ass
across the Roosevelt room carpet so
that's
oh we can't see here
oh my goodness big smile on his face
when things the fine family is doing
instead of watching The GOP debate
number two Nick de Paulo surprise
gifting zelenski this F-35 you mean the
wow come on no no surprise it's his
birthday I didn't know like a Lexus
commercial it's fantastic and the number
one thing the Biden family is doing
instead of watching this GOP debate
number one is uh posing for a family
portrait
nude that's the yeah
family zip ties what
I just come out of a call by I don't
know
and actually the plus one of uh what the
Biden family is doing instead of
watching The GOP debate Nick to follow
the plus one Jill is setting Joe up with
a Hungry Man dinner in front of the TV
while she sneaks up to the linking
bedroom to masturbate to a painting of
Paul Pelosi that she purchased from her
son Hunter for 1200 bucks oh wow well
there you go that's enough that is a boy
you wrote that I know I did that's been
tonight seven plus one I was gonna say
[Music]
the chamber
that brings me back the bad memories we
have time for a short uh a short break I
think we probably do can you can you
hook us up over there tool man got some
fun stuff let's do a short break as they
uh recongregate for the debate yeah I'll
get one a minute
well go go ahead I can I can take care
of this all right you want me to go yeah
yeah okay I'll go and then you go to the
bathroom but once we get the uh yeah
hold on a second I have to staple this
once we get uh
we have people at work let's play it no
no no not right now debate's back on we
totally they wouldn't mess it up now we
missed it okay
volume we're here in California where
gas is nearing six dollars a gallon oil
is close to a hundred dollars a barrel
again you say drill baby drill but the
courts won't let you Mr ramashwami how
would you bring down prices without
immediately not drilling well look I
think that we do have to run through the
courts and get through that
administrative state to make sure we're
using the natural resources the other
thing that we can do that's easy Forever
Mr Ramos and IT addresses the national
debt as well as brings down prices put
people back to work we are using
taxpayer money to pay people more to
stay at home than to go to work that is
wrong that contributes to our supply
chain crisis it contributes to inflation
that's the easiest way to unlock this
economy and here's the other thing we
have to put the Federal Reserve back in
its place this is an agency that has
gone Rogue so in January 2026 when I
have the opportunity as our next
commander-in-chief we will have a new
chairman of the Federal Reserve who
places priority on dollar stability and
then most importantly send packing 75
percent of the administrative State
reduce the federal employee head count
by 75 percent within 50 of
unconsciousness
that are shackling businesses
the economy that's how we revive this I
asked you about gas prices
yeah go on to the next person please
I yield back my time like taxes are
higher than bevex hair
[Applause]
because when Joe Biden ran for president
he said he was going to end fossil fuels
then he realized to himself by the way
he did it with an executive order on the
Keystone Pipeline on day one why are you
guys using the regulatory system when
he's that's not the one we blew up right
that was that's a different one
conjecture I have a plan that actually
would not only reclaim energy
Independence but in in 2006 America lost
our position as the leading energy
producer on Earth I believe in the next
10 years with the right policies and an
experienced leadership in the white
house we can reclaim our role as the
leading energy producer on Earth and
that'll grow the American economy for
Generations
no you know the first thing I'll say is
what I saw United Nations is National
energy security is National Security we
need a president that understands we
have to partner with our producers
who is a guest energy Independence
fracking he's against drilling
president Lance Armstrong
as he's laughing like a schoolgirl is
when you're in trouble
and you took green subsidies that you
didn't have to take that because
I just did a plan out in West Texas for
American Energy dominance we're going to
choose Midland over Moscow we're going
to choose the Marcellus over the molas
and we're going to choose Bakken over
Beijing and we are going to lower your
gas prices we are going to get that job
done because it's important for our
national security it's important for
jobs and that's one of the best ways to
drive down inflation
is
that we don't have as much as maybe West
Texas but we do it but that was a
constitution so that's just wrong and
let's just get real here my plan will
get the job done and
the voters didn't even yes
[Music]
the cost of college itself because the
colleges are going to have to make a
decision do we offer do we expand the
gender studies Department knowing some
of those graduates may not have great uh
learning opportunities no they're going
to focus on things that really good good
choices get mad people in four years I
also just want to come back something
Dana asked last segment about 9 11
because I was just at the 911 memorial
with the families my wife and I
everybody is very touching to be there
in my life
Florida I end up getting through Yale
and Harvard Law School and somehow came
out more conservative than when I went
in and that is not easy to do had a lot
of opportunities to make money but I
wanted to serve and I'll never forget
coming back on the plane from Iraq uh
Landing in Coronado California North
Island and feeling that breeze off the
Pacific Ocean say you know what I am
lucky to have been born in America and I
think being able to serve and I'll be
the first president elected since 9 1988
was actually served overseas in a war I
think that's going to help me as
commander-in-chief to know how you see
these issues you guys having a good
night real lives at stake for people
that wear the uniform and we know the
governor but the media the media is
going to remember his attack on Trump
and now he's on that track yes that is
your track now to sentence you are at
war with Trump Congress is that a mere
19 if this sort of business you'd
probably all be fired in Washington was
that fishing lure sitting behind us in
2013 Governor Haley fired you for the
Senate strike back to tell her why you
should be promoted to CEO of the nation
instead of heart
certainly one of the things I'd say is
if you look at our national debt of 33
trillion dollars I would love to have an
opportunity to have this country how
pass a balanced budget amendment what
happens
if it falls on deaf ears a black guy not
wanting to spend number one number two
if you want to actually reduce our
national debt you have to grow up I got
my plan the Allen Iverson plan
Andre Rison as well Civic sectors number
one Pac-Man energy sector we could
create between three and three what is
he looks at her they just brought up
foreign
[Music]
Sheets Were Made in America 27 trillion
dollars we brought the wonderful schools
in America Hispanics and Asians to the
lowest level I've been waiting for the
Secretary of the country
for women Adrian rice was I don't know
Adrian Peterson's the guy who's
witnessed this kid okay like I said
pretty confusing you're good a long time
but he's been there 12 years and he
hasn't done any of that he hasn't
they've only given me later even in the
kitchen 12 years you have yet to make a
good pot roast that's it that's it
come over there
look at the diversity do you see what it
does
see what diversity does it brings us
together give me four pasty
white guys in their 90s
I mean seven how many times let me
finish the first guys I appreciate a lot
of the things they're saying the only
one up here sounds like Paul
victories for the people of Florida
[Applause]
let's talk but when when it gets hot in
there when they're shooting arrows at
you are you going to be stand up for
people right keep the state free are you
going to be able to do all those things
State of Florida
the Democratic party lies in Ruins
they've got food people respond I can't
believe it saying they've done it While
others have taught us
just wanted
zero based budgeting That's the Way
businesses are actually right start with
zero as the Baseline for the budget and
then see what's actually necessary there
is a blue state or a red state in this
Union that doesn't the federal
government doesn't do it but successful
companies including the ones that I've
built as a CEO
the governor burgum runs yes
I'm still here guys
you say nobody else has done it the
energy
by these other folks on stage
the Border plans already talked about
we've got troops down at the border
flying helicopter missions from North
Dakota from San Diego to the Gulf Coast
trying to stop transnational criminals
from inflicting the invasions and his
eyebrows back in the 70s it was the
ellipse of the Equator
nobody else done the big fight North
Dakota was leading the charge we won the
battle to get the Biden Administration
was ignoring the law they were the first
Administration since Truman that wasn't
holding the holding higher lease sales
and we won that in federal court wotus
we won that in federal court we're
fighting the Biden Administration on 20
fronts to say that nobody's fighting the
big fights just look at the record of
what we're doing right now energy
economy National Security have been
talking about it since day one and now
finally good we're having the
conversation about it but we've got the
Canadians out you're having it with
yourself
we've done it in North Dakota yeah when
I took office We Shrunk the state budget
general fund by 27 in the first four
months I was office
job there's 10 or 20 percent of
mind-numbing soul-sucking work that even
the state and federal employees
two million civilian employees and by
the way we've got 10 million jobs the
only way he could be creepier is if he
said look into my eyes yeah
totally possible to do it if you have
somebody that understands because having
worked in technology for 30 years
everything we had to do it doesn't seem
like they've rigged this a little bit
like like they want to make it seem as
though this guy is relevant
[Laughter]
22. Dana just starts orbiting him
independent what is with Santa's face is
it's like he doesn't know when his
Smiles grin let's walk in Victory in a
governor's race and the history of the
state over 1.5 million votes we were
winning places like Miami-Dade County
Palm Beach that nobody thought was
possible uh because we were leading with
purpose and conviction I reject this
idea that pro-lifers are to blame for
midterm defeats I think there's reasons
for that uh the former president
um you know he's missing in action
tonight he's had a lot to say about that
because you should be here expect Trump
drink comments to try to say that
pro-life protection is somehow a
terrible I don't think you want to pick
that fight actually I think he's this is
a good entry point if he's going to he
is but I just think he's gonna get beat
he's put himself look guys you can
comment below and again hit the like if
you're watching on rumble or on YouTube
it helps with the algorithm the drinking
game has done its number yes
um this is one of I just think he's put
himself on a one-way track now he has to
be at war with Trump which is not the
best thing to do with some one was a
double-digit lead I think that'll hurt
him
supporting abortion all the way up until
the moment of birth that is infanticide
Governor Christie do you think have you
eaten children Governor Christie tell us
police report says
up to three months the very tender after
that day yeah because I did in New
Jersey Dana you know it's and why are
all these other states losing well
because they don't have leaders in those
States who are leading the fight the way
it should be left toxic is a successful
government I know only Blue State that's
represented up here this is where the
fight is really tough that's why we
don't believe you right we're gonna have
to try to win if we're going to win the
White House back and what we did is 14
times Dana in eight years I vetoed
planned parenthood funding 14 times
no one else gets it that much the
Democrats just kept sending to me and I
kept saying no because I believe in life
but I also believe in states rights and
I think we fought hard against Roe
versus Wade for decades to say that
states should make these decisions so
we're going to have those fights in the
states what you need is a leader who can
talk to people and make them understand
that if you're probably yeah we do but
yeah for the entire life not just the
nine months oh this is a literal
point public education subsidized health
care it's are you Pro this is why you
don't trust him right away he's using a
liberal bumper sticker I'm pro-life
after they're born which means taxpayer
subsidized education taxpayer subsidized
Health Care taxpayer subsidized uh
daycare that's what they do are your
pro-life well then you have to pay for
everything ever if you got elected in
New Jersey Connecticut New York you're
not a friggin Republican 70 of
Independents and 51 percent of Latinos
because I told them the truth from my
heart thank you vice president fans
by the way Alex Jones coming up as a
recap after this and this lady is
attractive I'm not going to absolutely
doesn't care about it
with that weird reverse mole the
Hispanic community
into Spanish
in this country
you know I'm incredibly proud of that
you know tax cut and tax reform bill I
worked on Capitol Hill to help get that
bill passed into law the largest tax cut
in American history we saw literally the
lowest unemployment ever recorded for
Hispanic Americans lowest unemployment
ever recorded for African Americans
50-year low he says
wrong
these talking points are correct which
is discussing the successes America but
then he wants to distance himself from
Trump when it's convenient that's why no
one trusts you you're right it's record
low unemployment for Latinos record low
unemployment for African Americans but
who did it who did it who's at the top
let me hear you say we turned our back
on Trump yes uh exactly and so help me
God Senator Scott reaction hey don't
bring him into this yeah he's gonna
start with a lightning bolt if you lead
by example it's the best way to get the
job done
in the Senate my chief of staff is the
only Hispanic female Chief of Staff in
the Senate okay I don't want to hear
about that anymore I don't care I'm
tired seriously I'm done
moderators goes thank you first is that
Jesus H Christ gracias uh uh to finish
my conversation with me
that needs to get done
at 10 every time I look at Gerald I see
God
I've seen a federal government a
portrait of Nick as David and Gerald
South Carolina and it's more like yeah
sister
you literally bring it fifty thousand
dollars don't say that to a black man a
15 million dollar subsidized step to
this Tim ring it fixed you got bad
information first of all I fought the
gas tax in South I got it from
BT against it
what if you just said bring it and he
just went s-e-o-t-t man
you don't know me and you don't know my
style if you will give me
Worldstar
while I show you
the overvalued 18 million dollar
Mar-A-Lago estate by the way that was a
story that came out where the judge said
that Donald Trump overvaluated his
assets 18 million dollars tomorrow can
someone bring up the adjacent properties
that are also worth that are worth 18
million dollars and they're less than an
acre rights acres in case you didn't
understand that the justice system is
rigged totally it's not white black it's
not rich poor it really is a system of
rigged against your ideas you have the
wrong ideas you are guilty of wrong
think and you can have a judge rule
against you the idea that Mar-A-Lago 20
acres right on the waterfront there in
Florida right is worth less than 18
million dollars that is a political hit
job the likes of which and this is the
thing did you just dismiss it it's so
stupid did you see the picture of the
judge though she had blue hair
the guy look it looked like David
Brennan with a gray you could tell this
guy was a pot smoking scumbag
left-wing jerk off oh seriously
I'm on my club every day more of that
honestly I stole that from Meet the
Press I like it I do but no I thought
you were channeling you can see the hate
in his face uh for Trump
there's no justice for here and by the
way like I don't I mean I said this
earlier I'm not in the bag for anybody
like I do support Donald Trump because I
think he's the best candidate for the
job I think he will do the best job in
the office and it gives us four years
plus eight years which is 12 which is
greater than eight if somebody gets
elected right now as a republican
because I don't know who else is out
there eight years from now to run right
so that that's the math that I'm doing
right now
I didn't say don't go after Ron DeSantis
because Trump supporters are going to
now go after Rhonda or sorry don't go
after Trump Ron DeSantis because the
supporters of trump are going to go
after you it's because Donald Trump will
come knocking you're not ready for him
I'm sorry you're just not ready I am the
one who knocks he's he's like you just
it's like professional wrestling you
hear let's do it look look jail knock
knock who's you suck okay you're a
you're a big
Slappy with arm is but I'm a
governor you can't tell me that well I
guess you're governor of Arby's tastes
like throw up
tastes like throb that's what they call
them I would never look look I would
never say this I would never say other
people tell me that's Governor throw
because he's an Arby's sloppy
nobody would say something like that and
then Rhonda Santa is like say this guy I
know and I'm like yeah this guy he's
hilarious just point would use that one
more time you'll get your point across
there you're right though there's only
one authentic person in this race and
he's not on step that's authenticity
none of them have it no and it I thought
you were saying that because Jesse
Waters was on the screen
so here's the thing too Vivek I'm not
pro Vivic I was Pro Vivek pushing the
rest of them to be more authentic in
here yeah addressing issues that they
were trying to dodge right and this
entire debate tonight seems like him
trying to make friends yeah everybody
else on that stage it's never going to
happen by the way you can comment how
much do you want to bet that Chris
Christie's take a monster right now
I guarantee you he's not on that stage
when he come yeah when they come back
he's gonna have like a four foot piece
of toilet paper stuck to his shoe and
okay so just all sweaty for some
comparison on Mar-A-Lago so 449
Australian Avenue Palm Beach Florida 18
and a half million dollars here's what
you get
four bedrooms four and a half baths and
3 500 square feet not exactly twenty
eight that's the slums of Mar-A-Lago we
call it that's 18 and a half it's
section eight Lago and by the way the
New York Post which is uh sometimes
right lots of times wrong and usually
Sushi um they actually said everybody
around says that's at least a 300
million dollar property so it's uh it's
not 18 million dollars even those guys
are saying it come on everybody knows
this is a lie all right you put in an
offer for him he said look if it's 10
million if it's 18 million dollars I'll
buy 10 okay he said look look mar-a okay
let me put it to you that way right okay
let's say someone's selling that okay
for 18 million dollars right and I have
a problem I gotta solve I gotta say okay
look I want that
[Music]
thank you
all right let's go back to the debate
that's a pretty good Patrick but we have
we have to go back to well we'll check
back with Finnegan a little bit
afterward but uh
I want to hear Stuart Varney try to
pronounce her name again
I should be voted off The Island
15 seconds
I mean we're here like we're happy to
debate
Mike Pence hasn't said a words
[Applause]
[Music]
a drinking rule for one Vivek points
with his index fingers oh my God you'll
blow your liver up here mathematical
path yes Governor DeSantis
in order to try to beat president Trump
who has a command mentioned president
Trump after getting out all these guys
polls don't elect presidents voters
elect presidents and we're going to take
the case of the people in these early
States we're going to do in the states
again on the 2024 election Republicans
have lost three straight elections in a
row we were supposed to have a red wave
with inflation at nine percent it
crashed and burned not in Florida didn't
we delivered it in Florida and so we've
got to choose right we've got to win and
we need somebody that's going to be able
to serve two terms so
2023 they'll be able to address the
names we turn the economy around we
secured the border and we fended off the
threat from communist China as your
president
and you can thank the Cubans I believe
Governor Christie I believe
and directly and to take your questions
he did it for four years
what do you not know about Donald Trump
exactly I know thank you this guy's a
liberal let's be honest he is I still
got time dude so so chill out well
depending about your lifespan you need
to say dude
divided our party
I've spoken to people and I know
everyone else has who have sat at
Thanksgiving dinner saying will you get
your hands off the turkey conversation
anymore
[Laughter]
I have a different view on this I think
Trump was an excellent president but the
American Construction does not belong to
one man it does not belong to Donald
Trump it doesn't belong to me I got
refills coming to you the people of this
country and the question is who's going
to unite this country and take the
America First agenda to the next level
when we rallied behind the cry to make
America great again we did not just
hunger for a single man we hunger the
midwestern
okay
respect Donald Trump and his legacy
because it's the right thing to do
that's a good approach good approach
absolutely to take the America First
agenda to the next level and that will
take a different Generations
that's it 10 o'clock and we will see you
out on the campaign Trail have a great
evening thank you for joining us have a
great evening that's this evening's not
four syllables go ahead Nick you can use
the restroom uh before we bring on Alex
Jones I know he's been a trooper
absolutely 5 p.m Eastern every day
before we go to Alex Jones I know we're
going to have him on here and then we're
going to go to your
chats
um I believe that we do have Finnegan
hopefully he finally got to the right
place yeah uh one moment uh folks let me
uh go now to our on the ground
correspondent
Thomas Finnegan
[Music]
what where the hell are you
hi Stephen
you're not at the GOP debate that's not
where you are pretty sure I am no you're
in a bait and tackle shop that's what
I'm seeing right behind you you told me
to get to the bait this was the closest
one I told you to get to the GOP debate
you were at goop now you're at a bait
and tackle shop
what is happening
uh no I can't let me feel Oogie are you
talking about worms I don't even just go
have a good night just
[Music]
I don't know do we have them on retainer
all right we have kellyanne Conway I
guess we're doing uh this kind of still
has something in there so we might need
to empty it out because oh this debate
once
yeah absolutely right now they're all
walking into the spin room to give their
triumphant speeches to act like whatever
happened on the stage didn't actually
happen so they can clip it and put it on
social media but this this debate had
some clear winners and losers Burger
I've got a little bit more time than I
thought he would bergam bergam Berg rum
drinking game got the best of you yeah
I just thought I was doing well with you
where's my drink he did well but he
destroyed it that's always an excuse
shut up
it's okay Fox News screwed me too oh
geez
burgum got a little bit more time than I
thought Tim Scott got more time than I
thought and everybody spoke over Vivek
don't you hate Nikki
yes like right this is reasonable in a
lot of ways people can name that movie
line I hated her answer she was in
Mexico at least the first part because
Ginger Snaps telling me that the rest of
her answer was actually pretty decent
and I'm like well I couldn't hear it
after I was seeing red for the first
part of the answer where she was lying
through her teeth but honestly like this
this was a make or break for some of
these guys I think Pence
didn't resonate with anybody other than
the 80s hence is the worst it's not even
close yeah he was absolutely the worst
bergam did much better than him Christy
was pretty bad I will say this if I were
to pick a standout tonight and you guys
can comment below let's take a poll
we'll go to your chat when we go to The
Mug club uh exclusive portion Tim Scott
I think Tim Scott I'm not saying that he
did uh outstanding very well but I think
for him he did what he needed to do to
sort of to Warrant being on the shows
another I don't think he'll survive I
think he'll he kind of had a moment here
today where I think he'll probably be
thrust in front of the pack a little bit
I think he had a little bit more passion
I think he got in there I think he
allowed people to see who he was a
little bit and this right there this
picture on Fox News if you can bring it
up there tool man now that's why people
don't trust politicians Chris Christie
and Ronda Santos shaking hands and
laughing and people are going up wait
hold on a second we know that Chris
Christie is a is a leftist we know that
he's a liberal sympathizer and Ronda
Santa seems to be good buddies with them
this people don't want someone who's
Miss Congeniality they want someone who
is going to fight for them right
that's the takeaway yeah every single
time and I think DeSantis had some very
good moments whereas last time I didn't
really think he had any good moments at
all I thought his debate was terrible
incredibly stale I think there were some
moments that he actually looked bad
again you still got to clean that up but
he had much more positive moments than
he did last time but we do have Mr Alex
Jones on the line to give us his
thoughts whenever you are ready okay
um well first off again it's the promo
code Crowder debate night that gives you
ten dollars off later with crowder.com
and when you join Mud Club that means
that you get Alex Jones is completely
unfiltered Friday show every single week
it is scary to think about I love it
well it's funny is that it's not really
that scary when you tune in and watch it
oh yeah it's completely reasonable you
do it with a friend don't allow the
media to tell you who Alex Jones is make
up your own mind sorry do we have Alex
Jones tell you
hungry Nick
I thought Chris Christie was taking a
minute with Hannah I kept looking at him
I was getting hungry
um
all right and then I guess we're gonna
do this then we're going to go to uh to
mug Club is there anything else that I
forgot as far as plugs anything no no no
I think I think we did that do we uh
well actually I get another sponsor
potentially we want to hit uh Mr yeah
you know what before we bring on Alex
Jones let's do one more you know we
haven't mentioned them in a long time
the studios here are exclusively
protected by Walter and by the way I've
told you this before in the past
look they're attractive they're smooth
they're merchants of death they
basically sell themselves Walther
Firearms just try the Walther and you
will buy it try it you will buy it they
have the balls to sponsor the show
compare it to anything else out there
whether it's Glock whether it's Sig
whether it's just just take your pick
everyone who tries it decides you know
what I'm gonna stick with this uh a
really quick word from our sponsor
Walther and then Alex Jones
oh I did I wasn't Gonna Roll this spot
oh
my God horror films don't work I gotta
find it hit the spot without that wasn't
what I meant hey Walter and I just saw a
light turn on was I dark yeah I was
trying to put the spotlight on the wall
through over Nick's shoulder there where
yeah it's over Nick's uh left shoulders
I bet you find this right with it how do
you find the spot instead of spring
around with the lights
you're crying out loud
it's like putting salt in a freshwater
fish all right okay all right
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
movies just don't work when you've got a
Walter
yeah that was a quick cut we're not very
smooth tonight what was the uh what was
the Walther pistol that we fired at the
range the one Walter uh well the PDP no
no no so you know the one I have is a
special edition the PDP is available to
everyone and it's look just Google wall
for PDP review
it's this they don't have the money for
marketing or giant military contracts
and they have the balls to sponsor this
show you won't find a negative review
everyone who fires it says oh my God
this is the best gun that I've ever shot
in my life again I just get something to
defend your household you and yours but
uh obviously you know uh who I line up
with walther's Incredible unbelievable
and uh you can't do any better all right
do we have a stinger got it because we
have him here the man the OG to break
down the debate Alex Jones
thank you
[Music]
why are we using that old Bill Hicks
picture of Alex he looks so stealthy all
right Mr Jones can you hear me and see
me sir
I can you know I've been watching you
guys all night one second hold on a
second I can't hear you because we have
to put you over the speakers I can hear
him but oh you can hear him all right
sorry Gerald is the only one who can
hear you because he has the headphones
on headphones on now all right go ahead
Alex that's good I was gonna say I
thought that I looked Sinister and
non-trustworthy with my uh Lex Luthor
haircut but let me tell you you look
like the ultimate Mexican drug lord now
with that special
bearded by it
I'm actually very yeah or like some like
Southern Kingpin or something yes you're
if you went to Mexico the one that would
all be tearing their clothes off and
throwing themselves at you so we you're
now the Mexican uh drug lord look that
looks good I don't even know why I did
Nick loves it so he just tells me to do
it so I I do it every now and then just
you know I'm just trying to try
something new just like one time I read
that you know drinking a glass of wine a
day is good for your heart so I started
smoking wine dipped cigars it didn't
work Alex uh of course people can join
up mug Club they can listen to your show
on mad maxworld.tv but every Friday
completely unfiltered they get your show
on mug Club Alex did what were your
thoughts on the debate tonight who was a
standout what was your takeaway brother
well let me just say this uh I've been
covering debates for a long time doing
the live coverage like you do but I I've
been watching since it started when I
was driving in the car up here to the
studio I was also listening to it and I
really think all the points you made uh
were dead on and and I'd like to make a
few comments on the points you guys made
but I basically agree with your analysis
but but let's go somewhere that unless I
you know tuned out for like five minutes
and I was taking a piss or whatever and
missed some of it that that five minutes
Alex that's a luck well I mean Alex
you're the prostate
that's what they said we have a very
small opinion if you have a small black
or large platter then you have a large
small bladder you have a large penis
and a very large bladder
no but I was actually taking a dump the
point is I took a five minute break I
don't know I mean I'm serious actually I
took a phone call and some other stuff
my point is is that I listen to almost
all of it and watched almost all of it
and my big takeaway is this we saw them
in
the last Democrat primary
with uh Hillary you know back in the
last real election when Trump won in
2016 totally freeze Bernie Sanders out
and I don't like Bernie Sanders
but clearly he was winning in a bunch of
states and the Democrats said we don't
care
we have super delegates that are going
to vote in California and other states
like New Hampshire for Hillary so they
stole that from him so he's like I hate
him not as much as Hillary it was wrong
to see that done and so now they've
changed the rules even more where RFK Jr
has been completely blocked out of it
they're not even having Democrat debates
right and how did we get to this point
so we're having Republican debates and
and Trump overshadows them uh he gets
like 55 60 of the field all the rest get
like 40 45 percent and so they're kind
of the Keebler elves they're the little
uh little abusions especially since they
indicted Trump it's turned him into a
folk here oh Trump's not perfect but
people see through this it and so it's
throwing massive support behind Trump
that's why scientific establishment
polls that are already quote skewed
because they sample more Democrats show
Trump 10 15 20 points depending on the
demographic in Washington Post ABC polls
against Biden so so yeah their attempt
to destroy Trump has made him the
Juggernaut made him the Colossus and
everybody else our little potions but I
do think it's healthy to have other
people in the field to have a wide field
to bring in new ideas that's what this
is all about but because Tulsi gabbard
scared the Democrats two and a half
years ago in the last general election
of the things they've Frozen them all
out so no one's talking about no
Democrat Party debates and they've now
changed the rules even more where Biden
is basically running unopposed and that
means when he steps down whoever they
replace it with now Rogers okay Alex can
I ask you something really just for
because you've been covering this for a
long time like I've said you're the OG
um but some people out there you know we
have a lot of younger viewers meaning in
their early 20s they may not know about
super delegates and I've talked about
this before that is I mean for the
Democrat Party right quote unquote it is
one of the least democratic opponents
can you explain to me and then continue
with your point but explain to people
who may not be familiar with the idea of
super delegates because that's a huge
part of the Democrat Party
well that's right the oldest party in
America is the Democrats
and there was one other party the wigs
that you know went away and it wasn't
until Abraham Lincoln came along with
his famous debates running for president
the Republican party was created and it
was an abolitionist anti-slavery parties
on the upside down world people think
the Democrats are against slavery
Republicans are for it it just shows
what you know total quackery all this is
and so the Democrats in their rules
going back 200 years plus have always
had the capacity to rig elections uh
they've never done it to this extent but
then when uh Bernie Sanders was winning
in a whole bunch of States including
California we even interviewed a couple
of super delegates when we were in New
Hampshire my reporters Richard dreves
it's an incredible clip of tens of
millions of views at the time and he
just walks up and talks to me oh I hear
you're a super dead like you were just
talking to see it and he goes yeah you
know Bernie's going to get the majority
of votes here in California other states
and I'm a delegate in California it
doesn't matter because we're going to
give the votes to Hillary and then
indeed that's what they they did so it
didn't matter once the Democrats voted
they the the party delegates were
supposed to honor the votes of the
general uh you know uh election in the
primary but that was completely and
totally ignored now they've changed the
rules and RFK Jr lays all out these
speeches he's given but I'm going to
look that it's true where if he
campaigns in Iowa New Hampshire a bunch
of other key first Battleground States
then he's not eligible to be on the
ballot and so the Democratic party at
the DNC talk about dictatorial they call
the Electoral College bad
dictatorial is they are allowed to
change the rules and look I like Trump I
like the fact he's taken over the
Republican Party compared to Chris
Christie and people but he's certainly
not perfect the Republicans
are now announcing and it's gotten
almost no coverage that they Trump's not
just not being part of these debates
which I think you know wisely hasn't
been he's way in the lead that's okay in
my view but
now Trump as the Republican party set I
saw this in the news last week in like
red state to go and do the same thing
Democrats do and have the RNC vote to
pull the same Shenanigans and basically
bypass primaries so this is very
dangerous de-evolution uh into a
two-party and then one party stated
Senator Josh Howley has worn to this a
lot of others have right the the
Democrat deep State and now the
Republicans are copying it because you
know trouble come trouble Go Trouble win
he'll lose and go to prison he won't but
but everything's moving towards total
and complete centralization and it's
very very dangerous I mean here's an
example okay and then General has a
question for you but yes please go
you know about Canada because you you
know are a dual citizen I remember
correctly unfortunately most Canadians
mobile it's a beautiful country
my Canadian citizenship entirely but but
yes well it's not a smear I mean
basically you know Austin is more
liberal than Canada so let's not bashing
okay okay I agree with Tucker Carlson we
should actually invade Canada and forget
and make you the president with that
mustache but seriously done
if you look at the charter of Canada
uh King Charles is actually in control
of it this is some weird right-wing you
know fake thing this is real no
the king of England anytime he wants or
his Governor General
can't dissolve the Parliament and can
install a parliament in the charter if
they want so it's the same kind of crap
when we look at that and say well that's
dictatorial that's tyrannical well just
like the king of England or the Queen of
England can have a governor general
basically remove the government when
they want to install puppets that's what
the Democrat party's done
and that's what the Republicans are now
doing and so this is a very very
dangerous situation for him okay so I
understand what you were saying with uh
with uh uh Bernie who who are the
Republicans in the bag for this time
around are you saying that Donald Trump
is the person that they're basically
saying hey just bypass the primaries or
are they going for somebody else that
was on the panel tonight of of
candidates that were debating
there are different factions Gerald
you're as smart as I am or smarter and
early on they wanted to send us uh
DeSantis was very popular yeah uh but he
was ahead of trump as soon as they
indicted Trump he went from neck and
neck with DeSantis where Trump was
getting 30 percent sanus was getting 30
in polls and all the other candidates
were getting you know the other 37
percent and as soon as they indicted him
he went up 10 points and each indictment
he goes up five ten points where he's
now 55 60 points ahead of them in the
entire field he's 10 to 20 points in
skewed polls that oversample Democrats
and so it's just like Hillary the memos
have come out the emails have come out
she told Fox CNN all of them to the CFR
she said
I believe Trump's the easiest to beat in
the general election I want you to give
him all the coverage and not the other
people and then it backfired on her or
you can say there's some sick thing
behind us and by the way and just real
just starting today she's been saying
hey by the way Putin's gonna meddle in
the election again right so so that's
why again keep in mind YouTube said
you're allowed to actually question
election Integrity now because they're
bringing out the same old Tire Trope
Hillary Clinton said I believe that
Putin's gonna meddle in the next
election because remember the election
wasn't fair and legitimate that was a
2016 talking point from Hillary Clinton
so she's done an about phase
all right
well that's right it's deja vu it's the
same thing where Biden says in a bunch
of speeches when I win the election
immediately surge the Border we're going
to open it up for everybody and then now
in New York and in Chicago and San
Francisco people are going we got
hundreds of thousands of people sleeping
on the street crime has exploded we
don't have money to pay for this and
suddenly they're like oh no you know the
the New York Governor says don't come
here we don't want you when a year ago
she was saying come here we want you so
they think we have amnesia and Stephen
that's a great parallel that you just
brought up of how they think that we
don't have memories and I'm sorry most
the public does not have memories they
do for baseball or football
but they don't when it comes to this
bait and switch they do over and over
again and that's really the problem I
think Nick had a question for you yeah
one was twitching like Alex what's the
alternative I know you say it's
dangerous if the Republicans stop
pulling the same Shenanigans as the
Democrats are doing as far as super
delegates what's the alternative to
watch them steal another election if one
team's uh playing you know not playing
by the rules don't you have to not play
do you have a chance talking about the
Republicans trying to rig the primaries
more so
okay
I still I think the broader points still
something to answer right yeah yeah
no but I think what he's saying is true
that I think I was gonna make that point
this climate of open fraud
this climate of all these dead people
voting this climate of hundreds of
millions of dollars what was the last
number it was something just
astronomical that Zuckerberg spent
getting all the names of dead people and
people that have moved out of districts
to do that so yeah when you're dealing
with a tyranny that's what Trump's doing
right when you're dealing with attorney
you tend to like we were fighting the
Soviet Union we set up a system to
counter him but we lost a lot of freedom
so you're actually right that that that
my instinct is I don't want to lose when
I'm getting my ass kicked I'll start
cheating
um the thing is conservatives and
Christians and populists we don't even
know how to do it like I've even sat
there and like God there's a war game
not that I'm going to do it but I've
thought about it well if you know we
start going out and getting violent with
it is that's going to work then I think
through it no that's not going to work
okay well if we do I like you know do we
get dead people to vote well we don't
have you know billionaires spending 400
million dollars here or whatever for us
to do that to get dead people's things
we just don't have it built into our DNA
and so what they can't beat here's a
perfect example they have these quote
scientific polls by ABC NBC Mason Dixon
all of them uh Washington Post where
they put in 10 to 15 percent more
Democrats and they just say we believe
there's more Democrats backed into it
and then they know key demographics Key
phone numbers they call key people that
have already been pulled before they
know by who they're reaching out to what
they're going to get they got 20 points
for 35 and under 15 points uh that
trumps up so Trump's 20 points ahead and
under 35. he's 15 points and a bunch of
other demographics and 10 percent
overall in that poll and the other
skewed polls They Call Scientific show
that so that means he's 30 points ahead
yeah right and so and so it's the same
thing with uh good point with with a
massive election they've only got so
many dead people if you watch Texas two
years ago or four years ago or Florida
it's that same graph where Trump goes up
Republicans go up it's an organic curve
and then as soon as the polls close boom
they pop up above well they tried that
in Texas and Florida and a bunch of
other states they wanted to take they're
like oh they're gonna go blue but they
ran out of dead people and people that
have moved out of the district that
didn't know hey you may live another
state for 10 years you're still voting
in Kentucky and so you see them run out
of bullets and the Democrats just stop
and so if we have a giant landslide
just like we have a giant landslide in
the pole they can't fix it because
they're just splitting fake data in to
buffer it but if you go above 10 20 30
points with a massive Landslide you
can't hide that that's a very important
Point Alex because the reason I I want
to focus on this is because you have
some people out there and I see this a
lot by the way in the Republican
Groundswell the conservative Groundswell
saying why vote anyway it's rigged
they're going to find the votes there is
a way for this to be so insurmountable
and we are within that margin we're not
within the margin of Victory again the
wapo ABC poll has Donald Trump ahead 10
points they had Biden had I believe it
was 17 we had those sources earlier
that's a very very left-winning total
spread a 27.
the point here isn't that you need a
margin of victory for swing States it's
we can have a margin of Victory so large
that they can't they can't overcome that
with these Shenanigans and I think it's
important for you to say what you're
saying because that's galvanizing as
opposed to defeating because you know
there are a lot of people out there yeah
on the air waves who tell people who
deliver a message that makes it sound
like well you might as well not go out
and vote all hope is lost right what
you're saying is is correct and I want
you to continue let me use a fight
analogy I mean let me use a fight
analogy let's say you weigh 200 pounds
you're pretty tough it's been a few
fights you're not looking for trouble
and you're 30 years old and you got you
know your eight-year-old daughter
playing at the park and some gang member
walks over while you're at your car
making a call and punches your
eight-year-old daughter in the face and
knocks your teeth out I don't care if
the guy weighs 100 pounds more than you
as the next convict who's killed people
you're gonna beat his ass and when I'm
saying politically is they may outweigh
us for 100 pounds they just knocked our
kids teeth out we've got to vote we've
got a rally we've got to be aggressive
we got to be out there and we gotta fly
Republican Americana Flags everywhere
where if they steal it again it's even
more obvious because if you give up and
say oh it doesn't count you're screwed
the top scientists top top people that
study this like Professor Epstein not
Jeffrey Epstein and others have done the
numbers and and they've only got with
dead people and people moved out of
District maybe 15 points they could
swing we give Trump or any other
Republican 15 20 points over the top
they cannot beat that and that's why
they're crapping their pants they're not
doing it with machines that's all the
red herring they're doing it with dead
people and mail-in ballots and people
voting in other people's names that are
outside the district it that's how
they're still in the election absolutely
and and Dr Robert Epstein we actually
interviewed him we're going to be able
to air that probably within the next
week or so I know you've been talking to
him he's he's somebody who's on the
Forefront of that with Google swaying
the elections essentially and the
numbers are staggering and you're right
the only way that we can combat this
right now is shine a light on Google and
make sure that they can't do the things
they were doing they've done that and
they did it in the 2020 run off the
Senate runoff election they had in
Georgia Congress is starting to get on
their own Congressman nothing I was a
congressional hearing Cheryl five years
ago where Sundar but shy the head of
Google was still lying to them that
Google Tracks phones it's on the damn
app it's the basis of it okay and and so
they knew nothing they were like Helen
Keller Jeff Dunham and blind five years
ago they now know the CIA is involved oh
there's think tanks oh they're censoring
so their education curve is going
straight up so we have to play catch-up
folks but here's the deal we were like
nowhere five ten years ago we're we are
our curves going like this their curves
going like that and that's sorry
interrupture I'll go back to you but
you're fine that's why Clapper and all
of them came out and said Trump's gonna
kill us he's going to arrest us this
week he's going to win we're all screwed
the they're the ones trying to arrest us
my reporter my my anchor goes to jail on
the 24th for months for peacefully being
at the Capitol so so they're hitting the
panic button we've made them take the
mask off and so it looks scary as hell
believe me you know we're all on the
crosshairs but folks we're winning I'm
not gonna lie to listeners we are
starting to beep the out of these
people I love it look Alex hey we'll
hang out with us for just a couple of
minutes
minutes really quickly you Nick all the
time for three hours you're a little
you're a little hungry
I want to hear what you have to think
about the debate give me one more minute
Nick you're a little hungry I saw that
earlier I think we actually had some of
that pudding maybe out uh at the at the
main table did we have that yeah oh yeah
that's right oh do we yeah we did
[Music]
what are you doing man oh I'm frying the
new pudding from my Patriot Supply but I
got them admit it's okay it's not great
dude you're not supposed to do it like
that you got to put water in it man how
much have you eaten
um
all of them
oh my gosh here try that that's better
come on it's instructions oh that's much
better of course it's much better man
you know you're gonna have to buy some
to replace that right right I'll just go
to preppaccrowder.com and get a three
month supply perfect you're probably
gonna have to do that twice Yakuza what
in the world are you doing
serious from pancakes
no I'm fine thank you
where's the gag reflex when you need it
[Music]
all right all right so prep with
crowder.com you get a 25 what is it 25
off a three-month membership there we go
perfect no three-month Supply yeah I'm
not supply not members and by the way
their stuff is great they have actually
sent us more oatmeal and put their
pudding is legitimately better than the
jello water yeah you need to add water
some of those powdered bread with
Crowder replica.com let me let me say
something about this because they've
been my sponsor for 15 years no no I'm
serious no I like I don't want to get
the best companies to be our sponsors
and you this stuff is better than what's
sold in grocery stores for a third of
the price they started out 16 years ago
they've been the biggest company for 10
years because of their quality because
of the huge variety they've got if
you're getting storable food your
sponsor is the way to go folks you're
insane in this climate in this world if
you don't go there and use that promo
code right now well thank you very much
this man's a pro hey can you bring up
the URL for people to sign up to uh for
mug Club through Alex is it
jonescraider.com yeah I got it coach
hey Alex
I I got to interrupt everybody here this
is pretty interesting news unrelated to
tonight we'll get to the wrap-up of the
debate really quickly but bring that up
so apparently the Arizona State
Treasurer has just gotten noticed that
uh she is serving as the acting Governor
because I guess something has happened
with Katie Hobbs where she is no longer
the governor of Arizona what really this
is I said is this real do we know why
they don't have they don't know why and
it but it's a republican that's now that
can can uh Mission Control get us get us
the reason why I'm assuming election
Shenanigans but that would probably be
if the reason is unknown for this but we
will
this is seismic read it to us there's no
reason given here right read it
so this is the Arizona Treasurer
Kimberly Yee statement on serving as
acting governor and and to everything
they've said that this is real if this
is like some kind of fake sorry but I
think it's real uh it says I have been
notified that I was serving as acting
Governor beginning later this evening
until mid-morning tomorrow while I'm
pleased to step just until mid morning
tomorrow guys just till tomorrow come on
unless you have to take a potty break no
she's probably first freaking paragraph
they do that when you go on to
anesthesia for Chrono yeah could it just
be that maybe she's pissed is it a heavy
flow month I really don't know that's
what I was thinking maybe she had a
stroke or something took too many shots
I have no idea maybe she was playing
tonight's drinking game but she's she's
actually stepped down at least for the
time something or maybe there's a
transfer of power I don't understand
like what I'm gonna do with a fight with
a hammer over here publicly though
that's not typical that's not typical
for this to be that public for a little
bit at least they say is this real
that's my that's that's my that's all
right and again she's the one just
declared this gun emergency which
they're really I'm really worried that
they might again I'm not saying Putin's
perfect I'm not a fan of Russia but I
mean you sit there and you hear Scott
and others up there literally saying we
got to fight the Russians over there so
we don't fight them over here I'm sorry
folks Sorrows from the globalist over
through the Ukrainian government nine
years ago they've been starting this
fight Russia started in Ukraine with
slavov the great his name was slav
that's what they call them all slobs and
the the West started this told us we
were going to win the West is losing
it's escalating the nuclear war now
we're sitting in f-16s Abram tanks
that's world war three as Bob said
blowing up Nordstrom pipeline too and
and giving them you know all these
weapons this is insane while our country
falls apart so I'm with RFK Jr I'm with
Trump listen the U.S is running this war
Nate NATO is run by the U.S the people
that run our country that have hijacked
it and I just want it to stop I wanted
to stop Putin said if you try to bring
them into NATO I'm going to invade they
said oh we're not going to do that now
stoltenberg said four days ago yes our
plan was to bring them into NATO and we
got the Russians to invade and now
that's expanded NATO so Russia's our
well yeah they manipulated
they've been to this so Russia isn't
trying to cut my son's penis off Russia
isn't trying to open my borders and
flood us like they've done Russia isn't
devouting my currency Russia isn't uh
doing all this crap Russia isn't trying
to say the Republican party is going to
be outlawed like Democrats so I'm sorry
I'd love to be a ruseophobe but the
chi-coms are up our butt the shy comms
are funding thousands of public schools
the chi-coms control hundreds of
universities the chai comes on four of
the six Hollywood they're buying
Farmland everywhere the chi-coms are up
our ass and and the globalists are
allied with them but Russia can't even
run their own country Russia is a mess
so that's why the globalists are doing
this because they're right the Russians
have not won this quickly the Russians
have lost hundreds of thousands of
troops but they got nuclear weapons and
they got submarines in the Gulf of
Mexico aiming at Austin and Dallas Texas
where our children live and aiming at
the East Coast and West Coast and
they've got 24 missiles per submarine
cruise missiles that are fired from 20
miles off the shore and hit us in three
minutes mach 10 cannot be stopped we
need to not have nuclear war yeah no I I
agree with you and and uh we'll probably
have you on here uh next week to discuss
that more because that's something
that's been really convoluted but uh
before we go to to mug Club exclusive
let us know your specific thoughts
tonight on the debate who you thought
the biggest winner was Mike Pence
I've been sitting there three hours yeah
yeah well Mike Pence is right on he's on
with Hannity right now we're going to
keep you in the mud Club but if you were
to say the biggest winners and losers
tonight with a debate aside from the
media being The Biggest Loser yeah
obviously Vivek ramaswani is like some
AI bot that just says all the perfect
tanks I don't trust him because I don't
know him but I would like to I'd like to
I mean I think he they all ganged up on
him as you said Stephen and as your crew
said because they're scared of him and
they said go after him I think Pence
like you said it's like you pull a
string it just says things platitudes I
like a lot of what Scott said about
bringing America together but I didn't
like his World War III stuff exactly uh
I thought that uh gnome did pretty good
uh you know I mean the guy that nobody
knows I didn't know who he was yeah he's
pretty smart Burger again none of them
it's good to cover it because it's new
ideas but because they indicted Trump
their Trump's got 55 60 of the field
unless he dies of a stroke next week or
something it it really is just academic
I mean who do you I mean I was listening
but who do you guys think is the clear
winner in this I don't think there was
any clear winner what I do think is that
DeSantis unfortunately has put himself
on a one track now right he he has to be
at war with Donald Trump he was the one
who decided to kind of draw that I don't
want to say draw First Blood because
Trump has been attacking him and I think
that it's worth sanctimonious but uh he
definitely I think made a mistake
tonight if he doesn't want to be in the
mode of DeSantis versus Trump so uh
that'll be interesting to see The
Fallout from that outside of that I
think that Tim Scott showed himself a
little bit more like you said I don't
like his answers on the you on Ukraine
that whole situation with the Ukraine
and sorry Ukraine and Russia I keep
wanting to say the Ukraine Russia but
then people say it's not that you you
kind of Ukraine
politics
um outside of that you know Chris
Christie was obviously very hungry he
makes good cookies uh gnome um really
should take it yes exactly
um I I think the important Point here
too to note is uh look
the media is is not your friend the
people out there watching the media
right now they are not your friend
especially if you look at Fox News oh
yeah what about that woman moderator it
was like she it was like he has a
Communist party or NPR up there oh
record attacks on LGBT record white
supremacy yeah no those are made up
statistics attacks on the LGBT and and
and and black people are almost
non-existent that's the real numbers
yeah no exactly and by the way when they
talk about these people who come from
other countries and I don't necessarily
know where she I would assume that it's
somewhat uh someone Hispanic um let's
talk about their record she's the
weather woman in Telemundo yes exactly
with uh lgbtq let's talk about the
record of anywhere else with lgbtq let's
talk about the record anywhere else with
diversity they always want to condemn
America for not living up to the perfect
standard it's like watching someone do a
high jump and saying ah you missed your
perfect philosophy flop there you didn't
clear that bar meanwhile they're not
even trying that's why they always try
and point to the United States that's
right the left never criticizes China if
you do if men kiss in public you get
three years in a labor camp okay right
okay so so so if you're a Muslim you get
sent to a uyghur concentration camp so
I'm sick of being lectured when I'm not
doing anything to gay people or anybody
else tell me yeah perfect now we're all
being called Nazis constantly and a real
Nazi they're hard to find 98 years old
from the SS who was in a unit that
actually killed Jews in mass in famous
massacres is being saluted and then
Trudeau came out two days ago and said
oh it's Russian propaganda no it's not
Russian propaganda they're so crazy they
had 330 whatever members 336 members of
the of the Canadian Parliament and not
one of them during this giant speech and
standing ovation he fought the Russians
in World War II what idiot does didn't
know who fought the Russians I mean it
is it is Polish tonight yeah no you're
you're you're ABS I thought that it's
two the Nazis I thought Christopher
Plummer killed off the rest of them a
long time ago I thought so too but we
are going to continue I guess obviously
of course on my club.com if you're
watching right now on Rumble you click
that button right there do it and you
get to continue watching on uh can I say
something about Rumble because I heard
you say this but I want to be clear to
viewers I got super excited months ago
when we launched this thing together and
as soon as I got ready to do it the next
few months you didn't even ask me to do
this fourth hour of my show is gonna go
subscription on Rumble through
jonesmotter.com it's gonna be massive
with the training wheels were just this
weekly show and you know it's a great
show some have been amazing some have
been okay we're really enjoying doing it
but ladies and gentlemen my home Studios
basically set up as I hit a second wind
at night I'm gonna
[Music]
thank you
closely on Rumble behind the paywall
because people want it it'll be
commercial free I can have special
guests say whatever I want but look at
the UK Parliament look at the EU look at
how Rumble said hey we got letters
saying take off Russell Brand that the
fight is there Rumble is what Elon Musk
wishes he was Stephen when he got me to
come over months ago point it out so if
we don't back Rumble and if we don't
back their hosts and if we don't support
their sponsors I know there's a lot of
big fish out there watching you should
advertise your furniture company you
should advertise your tech company you
should belly up to the bar you should
get on home plate you should get up to
bat and you should get involved because
there's no other thing that actually has
the the the the the wherewithal and the
infrastructure and the host all the big
top hosts are at Rumble people you want
us to fight you want us to engage you
want us to stand up you want us to not
back down okay we won't give up we won't
submit we won't sell out but we could
give out every everybody should go to
rumble right now everybody should
support Rumble because they're doing
what nobody else is doing and that's why
Stephen Crowder's there that's why the
rest of his great posts are there that's
why I'm there so if you want to win
folks get busy promoting Rumble and
Stephen Crowder and get busy over at mug
Club to build this infrastructure God I
really appreciate that that's why Alex
Jones is Alex Jones and if you unless
you're a furniture company and you're
Swedish because I don't need another
ottoman that folds into a bookcase right
now click that button we thank you
Rumble we're going to continue with Alex
Jones's wrap-up of the debate YouTube
piss off
[Applause]